so there's another guy who does what I
do he's extremely well respected he does
extremely good work I hate him he's
always been very nice to me when I've
seen him professionally just I have an
irrational hatred of him and whenever
his name comes up it like it drives me
nuts like people bring it like where we
hired him and I was like
because I hate him I'm really
competitive with him and so I will go
online and look at my book rankings and
I'll immediately check his and mind you
I don't look at anybody else's just his
if I'm ahead I've got this like smug
feeling and if he's ahead I get really
pissed off so anyway we had the
opportunity to speak at the same event I
don't mean like me in the morning came
in the afternoon like we were
interviewed together on the stage and
the interviewer thought it would be fun
if we introduced each other and so I
went first and then I looked at him and
I said um you make me really insecure
all of your strengths are all of my
weaknesses and when your name comes up
it makes me really uncomfortable and he
looked at me and he said funny I feel
the same about you the reason I had such
an irrational hatred of them had nothing
to do with him it had to do with me he's
my worthy rival he was a very cathartic
experience we've since become very close
friends and worked together I no longer
check his book rankings and because we
share the same cause we can actually
work together and so what I recognized
was so often in business we have these
competitors sometimes on our own teams
and so having worthy Rivals instead of
competitors competitors or other players
we set out to beat but the problem with
that is there's no Finish Line we're
obsessed with beating the the other
company then at some point sure you're
ahead in whatever metric you chose until
when that's not sustainable but rather
the other players inside our industry
outside our industry on our own teams we
can choose our own worthy Rivals their
strengths reveal to us our weaknesses
and by having our weaknesses revealed to
us it means we have the opportunity to
grow and improve and the infinite game
at its core is basically a game of
constant Improvement our worthy Rivals
reveal to us our weaknesses and our
opportunities to improve hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I quit on
my business partner I was making 300
bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from one of the best Simon signic and
get some of his incredible motivation
Joy
there's a great story of two two
Lumberjacks where every morning they
start chopping wood at the same time and
every day they stop chopping wood at the
same time and every day one of The
Lumberjacks disappears for about an hour
in the middle of the day and every day
he chops more wood than the other guy
and this goes on for months and
eventually the one who works all day
says I don't understand every day we
start at the same time every day we stop
at the same time every day you disappear
for about an hour in the middle of the
day and every day you Chuck more wood
than me where do you go for that hour
and the other Lumberjack looks up and
goes oh we'll go home and sharpen my ax
you know that that if you if you take an
infinite mindset it's not about how much
you can get done each day it's how much
you can get done over the course of a
career over the course of a lifetime and
and you you got to take vacations which
means you turn off your email and you
turn off your phone and you do not
connect to the office you know go
sharpen your acts like you do you take a
Friday afternoon off you know we have
something called duvet days in in our
company where uh um where it's you wake
up in the morning and you just can't do
it and it's not like asking you know
it's not like vacation days where you
plan ahead and it's not like sick days
you know where you're you're actually
sick like you're not sick you just
you just don't want to do it or I'm just
not feeling it today I'm just not
feeling it and you just you can do it
and you do responsibly you can't leave
your team in the Lurch obviously you
know we you have to exercise
um responsible freedom but we give
people an opportunity instead of lying
and pretending that they have a stomach
bug
um because they just can't face the day
that they can just call up and say I'm
I'm taking a duvet day and everybody
goes go go we got you you know go I can
tell you what I went through which is
what set me on the journey
um to sharing the message of the why and
and uh helping people find theirs
um a why is like a is like a it's like a
compass Direction it tells you where
you're going
um we can live our lives by accident
which is kind of like getting in a ship
and just sailing or getting in a car and
just driving you'll absolutely see some
amazing things you'll stumble and upon
some amazing experiences but you don't
really have a sense of where you're
going any sort of Direction in other
words what's it all for what the why
does is it provides a path it provides a
map or a compass so you will still have
some of those amazing experiences but
now they have value and worth and
they're taking you towards something
else it's a journey towards something
when I learned my why I had this
tremendous calm come over me a sense of
my confidence grew
um a sense that my life had more meaning
than I thought it had before and I had
now the choice a new way of viewing
decisions a filter through which to make
decisions which now I would ask myself
does this help Advance my why or not
does this help me stay on the path that
I'm supposed to be on or is this going
to be a random a random Adventure so the
why provides Focus Direction meaning and
and confidence you cannot have
Innovation or progress without failure
it doesn't exist
and if you truly aren't failing as
you're trying to innovate then you're
probably not pushing very hard because
you haven't broken anything you're
taking you're making very very safe
choices we could never put a person on
the moon without a bunch of rockets
blowing up first like of course
um uh um I I met a CFO once I asked him
the priorities at the company and he
said efficiency and Innovation and I
laughed and said well good luck with
that you know Innovation is inherently
inefficient because it requires
experimentation experimentation requires
failure
um much is said about fail fast I
actually
don't like the term that we I think we
overuse the term failure
um you know and the problem with the
word failure is it's like the word
cancer it's too broad like if you have
stage four liver cancer or you have a
mild melanoma those things are both
called cancer but they are clearly not
the same thing and the same thing is
when we hear the word failure some
people think failure means
experimentation but a lot of people
think failure means catastrophe and so
when we tell our company failure is good
fail fast that literally scares people
we don't want to fail so I think we need
a new word right we want to avoid
failure failure is catastrophic and it
should be avoided but Falling I think we
should encourage you know when a kid
falls off a bicycle we didn't tell them
they failed we tell them they fell and
what do we tell them get back up and try
again so I don't want to tell people
they failed I want to see people they
fail and I want to encourage them to try
again and you know brush off their knees
so I think we should fall and fall often
and I will judge the quality of
innovation not necessarily by if you
fell but how quickly you can pick
yourself back up and try again let's
reinforce that point because I think
it's an important one that fulfillment
is a right and not a privilege and when
we go out with our friends for dinner
when we used to be able to do that
um uh you know you sit around and
somebody says I love my job and
everybody goes oh my God you're so lucky
like they won something that statement
should be the norm not the exception we
should all get to go to dinner and say I
love my job and it's the one person who
says I don't that's that that we can
that we can intervene
um so yeah I believe it is a right and
we have a responsibility ourselves to to
find a a place where we want to work
with the people that we would work with
rather than just taking the biggest
salary
um that we have a responsibility to take
care of the people around us and we have
a responsibility to speak up and ask our
our leaders to work with us and create a
place where people want to come to work
where we where there's a safe space for
us to take care of each other and feel
taken care of so there's Mutual
responsibility all around
so when you say you know how do we do it
well it's it requires constant work it's
like how do you stay healthy well I can
give you a whole list of things you have
to do you have to eat right you have to
nurse your personal relationships you
have to get enough sleep you have to
exercise you have to meditate you have
to be mindful you know there's a little
there's like 30 things and you can't do
all those things well all the time it's
a striving
um and uh and when one's doing well
sometimes one one thing falls off it's a
striving and it's the same the the
pursuit of fulfillment is a striving you
know I I think it's you know this is why
I make the distinction between
fulfillment and happiness you know to
seek happiness is a lot easier because
happiness is fleeting you know you you
you get a new job you're happy you get a
raise you're happy you win a new piece
of business you're happy you're given a
gift you're happy you know somebody says
something nice to you you're happy and
that feeling goes away
no nobody nobody walks around with a
sense of happiness for a job they got
four years ago it's gone
um where fulfillment is different
fulfillment you can feel fulfilled by
your work even if you're not enjoying it
today
you can feel fulfilled by your work even
if you if you're having a bad a bad day
you know or or one of your colleagues is
grumpy you can still be fulfilled by the
work it's more it's more uh it's it's
more infinite it's more constant and so
um whereas happiness is you know the
things that lead up to it it sounds more
like an event fulfillment is a striving
it's a lifestyle and you do all these
things like having a just cause like
building trusting teams and working to
be the leader you wish you had in other
words you see your life as a life of
service to those around you whether
you're in a company whether you're an
employee whether you're a leader or if
you're just a parent that you see your
life in service you know to your spouse
your partner or your and your kids and
indeed your community what makes a
community highly functional is that we
view uh that every single person within
that Community sees their responsibility
to serve the community rather than
standing around demanding the community
does something for them I think courage
is external right the reason someone has
courage to jump out of an airplane is
because there's a parachute on their
back it's the external thing a a a a a
world famous trapeze artist would never
try a brand new death-defying act for
the first time without a net it's the
net that gives them the courage
you know the Navy Seals are considered
one of the highest performing
organizations on the planet and a former
seal was asked what kind of person makes
it into the seals
and he said
I can't tell you the kind of person that
makes it in but I can tell you the kind
of person that doesn't make it
he said the Star College athletes who
have never really been tested to the
core of their being
none of them making it
he said the preening leaders who like to
delegate everything
none of them make it in
he says the guys that show up with
hulking muscles covered in tattoos
because they want to show you how tough
they are
none of them make it in
he sent it he said some of the guys who
make it in are skinny and scrawny he
said some of the guys who make it in you
see them shivering out of fear
he said but every single one of the guys
who makes it in when they're emotionally
exhausted when they're physically
exhausted when they have absolutely
nothing left to give
somehow some way they're able to dig
down deep inside themselves to find the
energy to help the guy next to them
in other words the reason these
organizations and these people have the
courage to do remarkable things is not
because of their internal strength it's
because they have the absolute
confidence that there is someone to the
left of them and someone to the right of
them that cares about them
um and they will know that and it's the
quality of the relationships that we
maintain professionally and personally
that give us the courage to do difficult
things
Isaac Stern the famous violinist said
music is what happens between the notes
well something like trust happens
between the meetings you know we few
people think about the importance of
building trust when they go to work or
the what I need to do today to build
trust with somebody like that doesn't
really go through people's minds but we
have Chit Chat as we walk into the
meeting we've Chit Chat when we walk out
of the meeting and we see somebody the
whole they're like oh meant to tell you
something or you knock on someone's door
and be like got a minute and all those
little innocuous interactions over the
course of time like any relationship
build trust it's about setting up the
computer and setting up zoom and having
a work session with somebody you know
like we're not working on the same thing
but I want to work with somebody a work
buddy or having a lunch with somebody
over Zoom or a Monday morning huddle
where we talk about what's on our hearts
and minds but we do not talk business on
purpose or Friday uh cocktails that are
just voluntary but the most important
one is to just pick up the phone and
call people and say hey how are you
that level of empathy just check in on
someone and I think we neglect it
because we get mired in the day-to-day
but you know one of you know if you're
organized or disorganized you know
literally keep a list of your team on a
little card next to your computer and
just you know go through it and have I
called this person a while and talk to
us but I'm just going to call and check
in it doesn't matter if something's
wrong or not wrong just check in on them
you know don't wait for something to
Break
um and let people know that they're uh
that there's connection and there's a
way to reach out and say I need help
um because if if if and and the most
important thing is for leaders to be
honest and open about their need to ask
for help
and that that'll work finite mindset is
everything is about this transaction
this listing an infinite mindset is I
may win or lose this game I may win or
lose this transaction and there'll be
another one and another one and another
one and another one and the goal is not
to win this one the goal is to be better
and better and better and better and
better and what happens is you win more
often yeah so I I uh see and where I
struggle with that honestly is I want to
crush it every time yeah of course of
course
highly competitive A type personality I
get it yeah
um
but if that's all you do you you're not
going to be in the game I don't know
I've been in a long time but this is my
point in infinite in the infinite game
the infinite game the infinite mindset
is about having the strength the will
and the resources which means will is I
really still enjoy this industry and the
researchers is I got the money to stay
in the game if you run out of will you
run out of resources you find a
different line of work right the goal is
not to win every game the goal is to
stay in the game as long as possible and
you're more likely to stay in the game
as long as possible if you're enjoying
it and if you're making money
so uh but like I said think of those
agents who are better than you whether
they're better marketers or better
salesperson or they have they get more
recommendations and again you don't have
to like them you have to thank them and
study them and learn what they're doing
as I said because their strengths are
revealed revealing to your weaknesses
and sometimes partner with them because
you're actually stronger together
but hating them is stupid right
all it does is make you cut focus on
them rather than focus on yourself all
it does is make you focus and and sit
around with your friends and be like but
they don't do this and they well you're
not doing any of that either you know so
it puts all your focus in all the wrong
places
it's like you know what it's like uh uh
if the any skiers out there if you ski
through trees
every skier knows this if you say don't
hit a tree don't hit a tree don't hit a
tree you hit a tree
because all you're doing is looking at
trees
where when you're skiing through cheese
and you say follow the path follow the
path follow the path you don't hit a
tree because you're only looking at the
path so your mindset is if all you're
doing is focusing on them then you're
good you're hitting trees that's what
you're doing you're focusing all the
things that make you weak rather than
focusing on all the things that'll make
you better it's a term that's been
overused in business this concept of
authenticity right all that authenticity
means is the things you say and the
things you do you actually believe
and there's a lot of room for cynicism
in the in the in the uh financial
advisor World
um because every financial advisor says
the right thing I'm here to help you I'm
here to help you find your nest egg to
achieve your financial goals and blah
blah blah blah blah blah every financial
advisor I've ever met tells me the same
thing but then the way they make me feel
not always consistent where they may say
the right things but then they're not
actually listening to the things that I
want I can feel that they're just trying
to hammer a product
um they're not actually trying to do
what I what I ex what I talk about but
rather I can feel the feel that they
have an agenda that they're pushing
something on me and so you know we're
highly attuned social animals we can
tell the difference and if somebody's
going to put their agenda their uh uh
commission their interests first then
stop saying I'm here to help you and
achieve your financial goals because I
care about you
stop saying those words I don't have I
don't have a problem with somebody being
selfishly minded if they approach their
business just stop pretending that
you're not
because the ones that truly do care will
be way more creative if they say I'm
truly trying to help you they'll be
offering advice and forwarding articles
that have nothing to do with with the
financial tools that you can buy from me
I might send you an article about you
know your teenagers and and screen time
for example because you because that's
one of the things you're concerned about
and I'm here to help you live a better
life like I may be more curious about
all of the aspects of about helping you
of which some are the things that I can
deliver on within Financial advice and
some Financial tools so I think I think
if you got into this business to help
people then help people
um I think that's really really
important I think one of the things that
the the pandemic revealed quite frankly
was the weakness of so many corporate
cultures I mean we're we're seeing the
great resignation happening and if you
read articles or listen to some of the
Talking Heads you know the prevailing
thought as well they're getting you know
checks from the government so they're
not encouraged to come back to work
um or they're pursuing their dreams you
know which which we've seen as well in
our own company somebody wants to go be
a screenwriter and even though we have a
great relationship and they love their
job they they want to pursue their
dreams but the other the other thing
that I think is is underlying that it's
that it's missing that these these
commentaries are missing is that
um the cultures uh may have been weaker
than we like to think they are
um uh that the the sense of belonging
that people have when they would come to
work is actually a lot a lot more
tenuous than we'd like to believe so the
the the bond that's allowing them to go
off and do other things is is easily
broken
um I think strong cultures when there's
a strong corporate culture we recognize
that I can pursue my dreams and work
because I love it here and I know my
team is supportive of me becoming a
screenwriter or something and I can do
both or even though I'm making money
potentially even more money
um there's so much more I get from my
work you know the camaraderie the love
the support I get all of this training
on how to be a better listener and a
better Communicator which is having me
in my marriage and helping me with my
kids and I don't want to lose that plus
I I have my I have close friends at work
um and I can speak up and say hey I'm
I'm being offered more money from the
government is there anything you can
help you know the point is it becomes a
conversation rather than a rather than a
resignation so I think one of the things
that we're missing is this might be a
wake-up call for a lot of companies that
our culture is just not as strong as we
think they are you know it's been spoken
about for years that Millennials you
know and now gen Z are just not loyal to
work they bounce around from job year to
year to year well is that them or is
that us maybe if we had stronger
cultures they wouldn't want to leave
maybe if we offer them more than simply
Financial incentives for hitting certain
numbers that they'd want to stay maybe
if they felt that they were growing like
as human beings there would be things
that were more appealing to them than
simply simply a bigger paycheck
somewhere else
um so I actually think it's it's a it's
a big wake-up call frankly
um uh that that we we should go back and
look at our cultures and say are we are
we as good as we think we are the best
leader is actually the best follower is
even if they're at the highest levels of
the organization they're still in
service right it may not be to a person
but to a cause an idea a vision whatever
it is there's still some sort of
something that they're beholden to and
they're devoted to and they're in
service to
um so so followership is a thing
um and
um
not to belabor the Marine point but uh
you know Marines when they evaluate
their leaders they're looking good for
good leadership and good followership so
for example there when you go through
OCS officer candidates uh School
selection
um uh
when somebody's a for a task you know
chosen to be the leader of that group
for that task the the Marines are
watching the others as well so they're
looking to see that everybody's
contributing ideas and they're looking
to see that that leader takes in those
ideas but is decisive and and they're
looking to see that the the members of
the group if their idea isn't picked
they still give their all
to see that that the leader's idea is
successful and if it fails give it their
all to pick up the pieces and and see
what they can do as opposed to going I
told you right should have gone my way
right I was right or sabotaging because
their idea didn't get picked so they go
all in so so good followership is is as
important as good leadership that that
we we respect that that
um when a decision is made we will we
will give our Blood Sweat and Tears to
see that the decision our leaders have
made will be successful and if it fails
we will help pick up the pieces because
that's the deal when you're trying to
build uh trusting teams it's you you
recognize that you cannot enforce
certainty uh on people you can offer
goals people like goals
um but what's important is how we get
there not not just that we got there
think of it like uh think of it like um
trying to lose weight right there's
nothing wrong with setting arbitrary
goals or with arbitrary dates which is
by the way how we build our businesses
we want to to hit x amount of dollars in
Revenue by probably the end of the year
because that's when we pay taxes it's a
completely arbitrary number somebody
might say we could do better than that
you're like you're right and then we
change the number right complaint works
of fiction that so we're striving to hit
a work of fiction right
um
um and it's the same when we want to
lose weight I want to lose x amount of
pounds by X date arbitrary right and
we're doing all the things to do that
we'll you know we're exercising eating
well all the things we love standing on
the scale we love a metric there's
nothing wrong with that
um human beings need that we can't run
in a marathon without mile markers it's
actually unnerving we need to know how
fast and how far so the metrics are good
and let's say you hit your goal right
you hit your performance goal just as as
as you uh had articulated amazing you
feel incredible you feel like you've
succeeded here's the problem you have to
keep exercising for the rest of your
life right in other words you don't stop
doing the things that you were doing so
the game hasn't ended it was simply a
waypoint but what I think is more
interesting is what happens if you miss
your goal what happens if you don't lose
the amount of weight that you wanted on
that date and the and the answer is
nothing nothing happens because you're
probably way healthier than you are now
than you were you're probably on the
easily you can see the trend data you
can see you're well on your way to
hitting your goal you just pick the
wrong date you're easily going to hit it
in another month if you just stick to
your regime business is the same which
is sometimes we miss our goals but the
question is how what's the trend data
you know is the team working well
together is morale High
um is some of it out of our control you
know market conditions and things like
that things we didn't we didn't know
about and so if we happen to miss the
number the problem is is how are we
rewarding our people and so many of us
only reward Our People based on if they
hit the number but what if they're
begging borrowing and stealing what if
they simply Rush at the end of the
quarter to to drop their prices or have
some sort of promotion or or or or have
some some trickery they'll hit the
number
and then we bonus them which tells
everybody else I don't care how you hit
your numbers as long as you hit them
well guess what kind of behavior that's
going to reinforce inside our
organization
whereas if you look at the data the
trend data and you reward somebody who's
well on the path what we're telling you
is as long as you're doing a good job
you'll do well in this organization
leaders understand that they are not
responsible for the results they are
responsible for the people who are
responsible for the results and that
skill set is very very different than
just trying to get people to do the
thing that you know how to do better
than them because you've been doing it
your whole life when the pandemic struck
I mean my book came out a few months
before the pandemic and so for from a
from for someone like me who like who
loves to observe and like whether this
stuff is true or not you know you sort
of go you know you sort of Wonder is
everything going to hold up or not
uh and as an existential Flex uh is
something that I predicted would happen
either zero once or at the absolute most
twice in a career but when covet
happened we all went through it at the
same time existential flexibility is is
that you're able to make a profound
uh 180 degree strategic shift in order
to continue to advance your cause in
other words stay relevant
um uh this is not about the daily
flexibility of business this is we're
talking profound strategic shift here
um and sometimes brought on by pandemic
sometimes brought on by changing
technology or politics or culture or
tastes
um but you're able to adjust
um so for example it's um Apple Steve
Jobs when they're developing technology
in One Direction they just and they
discover this thing called the graphic
user interface that they did not invent
and they decide to walk away from
millions of dollars spent on countless
man hours in order to focus on a
different uh strategic uh position
because jobs believe that that was a
better way to advance his cause of
empowering individuals to use uh
personal computers
um that's that's existential Flex having
a sense of purpose cause or belief for
our work is what gives our work and
frankly Our Lives meaning
um you know when we die nobody wants the
the last balance in their checking
account written on their tombstone you
know nobody wants the last title on
their last business card on their
Tombstone we don't that's not how we
want to be remembered we want to be
remembered for the kind of person we
were in the lives of others you know
devoted mother loving father you know
these kinds of things
um and and we want to know that our work
uh had an impact in something bigger
than ourselves it's a very normal human
thing unfortunately a lot of people
don't start to think about thing those
things until later in their lives and I
heard this I usually hear this from
senior Executives believe it or not
where they say you know I've had great
success and I've done all these things
but but I don't want my I don't want my
life to end on this chapter I I would
feel like I've done something wrong you
know and they want to make sure that
they're that they do something
powerful and impactful in the lives of
others that that's how they want to
close the book on their lives what I
love about this young generation is
they're starting to think about those
kinds of things now
you know it's not unique to a young
generation everybody wants their work to
matter and have meaning I think our
young generation is just more vocal
about it which is wonderful so you say I
I've met this person that I really like
how do I build trust well you don't tell
them all your secrets on the first day
right we all know that you have to be
vulnerable but but there is there is a
there's a timing you know and it's a
dance and it's and it's giving somebody
a little extra
responsibility and seeing how they do
and if they screw up instead of yelling
at them be like all right try again you
know that we treat mistakes as learning
opportunities rather than you know and a
mistake is only when you keep repeating
the same error and you haven't learned
anything
um
where we practice empathy you build
trust with empathy as well so
um empathy uh in business looks like
this
um here's a traditional
scenario
somebody walks you know picks up the
phone and walks into their office when
we had when we did that
um and says
you know your numbers are down for the
third quarter in a row
um
we've had this conversation before and
if you don't pick up your numbers in the
fourth quarter I don't know what's going
to happen right that's pretty normal
here's empathy injected into that
scenario hey your numbers are down for
the third quarter in a row we've had
this conversation before
um are you okay I'm worried about you
what's going on WOW right where it's
about the person not the performance
and so when again it goes back to that
listening and you you are not listening
until somebody else feels heard
those things you know seeing someone as
human understanding that we all have
stresses and strains and Egos and
insecurities and we bring all of that to
work
and though we still have to be uh
emotionally professional you know you
can't sit in a meeting like this because
you're having a bad day that's
emotionally unprofessional
um though we still have to be
emotionally professional
um we're still human beings yeah and a
good leader uh recognizes that
and by the way somebody on a team
recognizes that too you don't have to be
a position of authority to be a good
leader you know because those who may be
higher in rank than us are also filled
with insecurity and fear and stress and
strain and ego and all that right and
it's okay to go up the chain of command
and say hey are you okay you know you're
really hard on us in that meeting today
instead of labeling them an [ __ ] be
like are you are you okay you know and
and by the way and that's the dance it's
like any relationship you know it's not
expected for one person in an
interpersonal relationship to to do all
the listening it's a dance and it goes
backwards and forwards and you know you
you you you meet empathy with empathy
and you meet listening with listening I
think very often companies can risk
becoming reactive to things that happen
in the marketplace which may so here's a
great example right let's use a real
life example Blackberry was a really
fantastic company who built a really
fantastic product with a really clear
sense of vision which is we make strong
secure extreme reliable products and if
you remember if you ever had a
BlackBerry
you could throw that thing across the
room drop it on the street and it just
didn't break it just kept working it was
the most reliable product on the
marketplace you could type on the full
qwerty keyboard without even looking
down you could send a holding email and
governments and big businesses loved it
because it was really secure and really
reliable
then the iPhone showed up and the iPhone
was the new shiny object
and blackberry instead of sticking to
their core and their beliefs became
distracted by the shiny popularity of
the iPhone which is a completely
different animal serving a completely
different audience and they started
trying to copy iPhone so they started
putting apps on their on their
blackberries which what did it do made
it slow and sluggish
um then they started coming out with
flat screens you're not going to make a
better iPhone than an iPhone
um and they basically destroyed their
company because they completely went off
the reservation and and abandoned their
fantastic cause there could be two
marketplaces where you have the shiny
objective of the iPhone that we use in
our personal lives and our companies
prefer that we use a a Blackberry
because it's reliable it's safe and it's
and it's really really strong
um and we could have had two dominant
players for two dominant reasons like a
PC and a Mac two dominant players are
two dominant reasons for do two
different reasons but they didn't they
got distracted and I can imagine that
their that their business people were
saying you know business is moving at
light speed we have to react
um or we can work to advance our cause
in a different way and not become
distracted and that's part of the hard
thing which is are we stuck in our old
ways or are we actually sticking to our
sticking to our long-term Vision that's
that's part of the the difficulty of
business to know the difference I would
sort of reject the concept of of blunt
honesty you know
um you can be honest without being an
ass
um uh you know do I look fat in these
genes I like the other genes better
that's an honest assessment without
making somebody feel bad uh for example
um and we also have to get good at
evaluating someone's personality some
people are more sensitive than others
and so a good leader is able to adapt
their style and how they uh offer
information so that um sometimes they
have to be a little more polite to some
and they can be a little more blunt with
another because their personalities can
take it
um what we want people to do is hear the
feedback hear the input
um uh and it's based on how they receive
it not how we like to give it we have to
be the adaptable ones
um as as as Leaders
um but he he's absolutely right that
good leadership starts with care and I
hear this all the time unfortunately
which is you know as a leader I didn't
get to uh I didn't get to choose my team
so why should I care about them or why
why should I trust them you know they're
not I didn't choose them well you didn't
get to choose your children you love
them
um and this is one of the the the the
risks of leadership you know leaders
have to take the risk to care they have
to take the risk to trust first I've
never in my life heard a great leader
say proved to me why I should trust you
to their team it's the opposite a leader
takes the risk to trust and it's the
team who says prove to us why we should
trust you that's the correct hierarchy
um uh so so yes you don't you do have to
care you want to see you want to see
your people as human beings first
um you know they are not the problem
they may have a problem and inject a
little empathy into the into the
organization this is what what reflects
care so for example I'll give you one
one example
um uh so here's a pretty normal scenario
somebody walks into an office and says
you know your numbers are down for the
third quarter in a row we've had this
conversation before if you don't pick up
your numbers in the fourth quarter I
don't know what's going to happen
empathy uh changes that you walk into
their office and you say your numbers
are down for the third quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before are
you okay what's going on I'm worried
about you that's empathetic that's the
expression of care that we recognize
that someone may have a problem but they
are not the problem there are many
people in your industry who talk a good
game they talk about relationships but
let's be honest it's [ __ ] they just
want to make the transaction and move on
and they pretend that they care and they
pretend it's you know that they care
about their relationship when the
reality is it's one and done and on to
the next and that's what happened to me
I I had a mortgage broker uh he sold me
a mortgage he was recommended to me it's
how most of us meet somebody you know
uh uh and he was very nice and charming
and
was there with me and then my my sale
went through
and he called me up to congratulate me
and I was feeling a little warm and
fuzzy towards him and then as soon as he
congratulated me said and if you could
recommend me to anybody else I'd be
really grateful like and he wasn't
calling to congratulate me he was
calling to remind me to put in a good
word for him somewhere else like if he
actually cared about me and my house
then he would have just called me really
excited that I got my house and if he
wanted something from me he would have
waited a week a week or two to ask the
favor but the guy it became abundantly
clear to me I'm in the human behavior
business yes he never called me
because he cared about me yeah and by
the way I will never ever recommend him
because it was never I realized that I
was just a number on a spreadsheet
and so if you actually care about
building relationships then actually
build relationships yeah you know
um I remember when I was starting out in
my career I had a young
a little marketing consultancy
and I came from an industry that
pretended that they were good at
everything the marketing world like
literally they pretended they were good
at everything whether they were or
weren't
and when I went out by myself
it was important to me to be honest and
clients would come and talk to me and
say we want to hire you to do all these
things and I'd say I'll do that when I'm
really good at that pretty good at that
I like doing that that I'm mediocre on
that I suck at I highly recommend you
hire another company to do that and I'm
happy to partner with them and it made
them want to do business with me more
because you said no because I told him
what I was good at what I was bad at
where I was super honest and we've all
had that experience where you want to
hire somebody and they go
you should let me introduce you to
something it happened to me recently
yeah I wanted a is it like something
silly yeah you know I needed wallpaper
yeah I I he highly recommended I called
him up he came he gave me a quote he's
like you know what I'm not the best at
this thing and he gave me the number of
somebody else yeah now all I want to do
is work with him again and I keep giving
out his phone number to other people
even though I actually never did work
with him yeah because what builds a
relationship is an honest broker
honesty is such a hard thing to get
especially in a transaction business
especially in a commodity business
because it is just volume in numbers
yeah and that when you actually find an
honest one all you want to do is help
them build their book of business even
though you may never do business with
them and that's what a lot of
finite-minded folks in your business
don't get yeah which is you may never
sell me a mortgage but I'll become your
biggest champion so listening is a trust
building exercise right if you've if
you're in a Rel take it down to a
personal relationship if you've been in
if you've ever had a romantic
relationship it's a loved one right
um
um making someone feel heard
doesn't mean you're wrong saying sorry
doesn't mean you're wrong it just means
you take accountability for your for
your actions and I think it is important
that when somebody objects to
vaccination that we don't demonize or
villainize them but we attempt to hear
them make them feel heard doesn't mean
we have to agree but they have to feel
heard and you know
listening is not hearing the words you
know it's making the other person feel
that they were heard it's it's it we
don't get to decide when when hearing
has happened when listening they do and
and by the way it's not 100 successful
either you know because some people are
just hell-bent on and but that's a
minority
and so I think the exercise of sitting
down with people and say tell me tell me
what's what you're going through tell me
what you're afraid of I want to
understand because we're trying to make
everyone safe I I want to I want to hear
what what your thing is and let them
tell their story we have no answers
we're not there to object we're not
there to react we're not there to fix or
tell them that they're wrong women are
better than this than men
um uh uh uh
and I think that has to happen and it
can happen simultaneously they are not
mutually exclusive
um I'll give you one one example
which is I have a friend who uh
refused to get vaccinated
and I sat down with her and I said
tell me tell me your reasoning
right
she goes well
um this new technology like I don't
wanna we don't know it hasn't been out
long enough like we don't know so what I
hear is fear of the unknown
okay I go go on and she I let her talk
and say her thing and explain all the
things and I and then and I simply said
so you're afraid of the MRNA technology
right yes and I want them screwing with
my DNA
I said well just so you know it's 20
year old technology but then I found
something I could agree with her but but
you're right
it is the first time it's been
commercialized you're absolutely right
that's the first time we've put it in
the market so I affirmed her fear
and then I said do you get flu shots
every year she goes I do I said okay
Johnson and Johnson is a good
old-fashioned flu shot it's a different
technology it's not mRNA so I you're 100
right if you're afraid of of the new
technology don't get modern or Pfizer
but Johnson and Johnson is it's just
like a flu shot it's the same old Tech
and she went it is and it is she went
and got a modern shot
[Laughter]
to be heard because most of her friends
when she said I'm not getting vaccinated
he yelled at her told her she was stupid
told her she's an idiot told her she's
letting her friends down told her she's
making other people sick told her she's
a risk to society
that doesn't make somebody's mind open
up all I did was let her feel heard
I think we do we can't we have to do
that we don't have to like our jobs
every day but we do get to love our jobs
every days like you don't like your
children every day but you love your
children every day so having a a hard
day you know that that's fine but the
question is is what do we fall in love
with and at the end of the day the
reason
um uh that we Stay or Leave a job is
because how we feel about that job you
know I think we we misunderstand when we
think people just leave for money if
they just leave for money then they
never really had strong feelings of the
company in the first place right because
when people feel loyal to the company
they turn down jobs that offer them more
money or if it's so tempting and the
numbers are so high then they go to
their company and say listen I was
offered this job it's very tempting
there's a lot of pressure but I don't
want to lead is there anything you can
do to help me stay right so and you and
there's the point is is there they're
open about it and and what makes people
want to have that conversation like I
said is that they're seen and heard
um the best companies
um have all kinds of programs inside the
company to help the person grow as an
individual now we talked about you know
listening skills and these kinds of
things these are valuable for the work
that we do but it turns out that those
skills also help us as parents they help
us as as as spouses or as boyfriends and
his girlfriends they these are valuable
skills in life
you know
um and I think that we forget that we
talk about hard skills and soft skills
as if those things are opposite it's a
terror I hate the term soft skills hard
skills and human skills and the more
that we invest in human skills in
addition to the hard skills that we're
teaching the more people feel like
they're growing as individuals I'm a
better version of myself now than I was
when I started at this company because
the company is actually helping me on a
in personal growth
um uh WD-40 which is a company that I
admire their their culture uh the
lubricant company
um uh they train their managers to be
coaches so literally like Executive
coaching training that kind of thing but
they train their own people to do to
have that skill set so that they're
equipped to help their people who have
challenges and especially with younger
generation you know the younger
generation is asking companies to
provide everything you know we want to
have our sense of belonging our sense of
community our sense of personal growth
our sense of purpose to come from work
work it didn't used to be like that 40
years ago
um and so and so there's a huge pressure
on companies and so I think what entices
people into the company and into the
industry is not just come and do cyber
security you know there's a percentage
of people who are you know de facto
interested in that but rather tell them
the kind of experience they're going to
have tell them what they get from the
company and you'll find it remarkable
how many people will all of a sudden be
interested in the in the category in the
company because of what they get
holistically not just what they get from
the product as a leader
um our responsibility is to make the
people feel that we have their backs and
actually have their backs
um so uh there's a sort of a nice
anthropological if you want me to go
down this rabbit hole there's a nice
anthropology I find it fascinating
there's a nice anthropological
explanation which I actually uh
explained in that book
um which is which raises the question
why do we have leaders
um human beings are naturally
hierarchical
um we self-organize all the time it's
got nothing to do with whether you have
formal hierarchy like in an organization
we we're constantly self-organizing like
in a sports team who's who's the better
player we self-organize and we pay we
pay deference to the one who is better
you know the scientist who publishes
more or the Nobel Laureate all the other
scientists pay deference right
um uh this is not by accident
um there's a very good anthropological
reason for it going back uh many years
you know human beings have only been
farming for the past 10 or 12 000 years
but we existed for tens of thousands of
years on the planet before that and we
lived in populations that were about 150
we maxed out at about about 150 which
raises a very interesting question we
they lived in austere times people are
hungry
um somebody you know brings back some
food to the tribe we all rush in to eat
um well if you're built like a football
player you can shove your way to the
front of the line right but this is a
bad system because if you punch me in
the face this afternoon I'm probably not
going to wake you and alert you to
Tanger tonight
um and so it's just a bad system for
cooperation which is if if we leave
every person to themselves
um and so we evolved into these
hierarchical animals we're constantly
assessing and judging who's higher in
the pecking order who's the alpha of the
of the group and when we assess that
someone is Alpha to us we naturally step
back we naturally defer and allow our
Alphas to eat first
um um and we get fed later and I don't
get an elbow in the face right good
system
this has survived to this modern day
there's not just not a single person on
the planet absolutely zero who has any
moral anger who is offended by the idea
that somebody more senior in the
organization makes a higher salary or
gets a nicer office or a better parking
space it offends nobody no we may think
they're useless at their job but the
fact that they make more money than us
because they're higher up in the
organization offends zero
um if you're senior and you leave your
coat in the other room someone will go
get it for you if you're a junior and
you left your coat in the other room you
get your own coat in other words you get
treated differently
and this is why people want to get
promoted because they like the perks but
the perks don't come for free and that's
the point which is as you make your way
up the hierarchy as you achieve that
Alpha status of the tribe there's an
expectation that sure will give you
first choice of meat and we'll give you
first choice of mate but if danger
threatens the tribe you're going to be
the one who runs head first towards that
Danger first to protect us which means
you might die first right that's why we
gave you first choice of mate because we
want to keep your genes in the gene pool
we're not stupid
and and it's When leaders uh shirk that
responsibility that we start to have
moral outrage so for example nobody has
a problem with a CEO making more money
than they do the problem we have is when
you're willing to lay off your people to
protect your salary to protect your
bonus rather than find other ways to
protect the people this is what morally
offends us we have we made a deal
there's a deep-seated anthropological
deal that we've made with our Alphas
that you have to protect us you have to
and you have to do what it takes
sometimes sometimes putting your own
interests second
um and then and then you can but if
you're willing to do that we're proud
we're happy go enjoy you've earned it
um and so I think this is this is a
large part about building trust which is
it's not just about saying nice things
and being trustworthy it's that people
feel that you actually have their backs
and that you would be the one who take
responsibility take accountability look
for other ways to protect us if it meant
um we're gonna get hurt they happen to
have a coffee bar uh in the lobby of the
Four Seasons in Vegas and so one
afternoon I went and bought myself a cup
of coffee and uh the Barista working
that day was a kid named Noah
Noah was funny and charming and engaging
and I spent far too long buying a cup of
coffee because I just so enjoyed talking
to Noah so as is my nature I asked Noah
um do you like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah said I
love my job now in my line of work
that's significant like is rational I
like the people I like the I like the
work you know I get paid well I like my
job love is emotional it's a higher
order connection right like do you love
your wife I like her a lot right clearly
it's clearly a different standard right
so when Noah said I love my job my ears
perked up
this kid has an emotional connection to
his work so immediately I followed up
and said tell me specifically what the
Four Seasons is doing that you would say
to me you love your job
and again without skipping a beat Noah
said throughout the day managers will
walk past me and ask me how I'm doing
ask me if there's anything that I need
to do my job better not just my manager
any manager and then he said I also work
at another hotel and there the managers
walked past us and catch us when we do
something wrong there the managers are
always trying to drive performance and
make sure we hit our numbers he said
there I'd like to keep my head below the
radar get through the day and just
collect my paycheck only at the Four
Seasons do I feel I can be myself
now this is the exact same human being
working at two different companies and
yet our experience of him will be
profoundly different not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he works you know I
get this question all the time you know
Simon how do we get the most out of our
people people are not a towel that you
ring them out to see how much you can
get out of them
you know it's it's a it's it's it's
that's a good one man
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a flawed question the question is
how do we create an environment on in
which our people can work at their
natural best and that is the art of
leadership it's creating environment in
which relationships can thrive in which
trust can Thrive and we all know what it
feels like to be on a trusting team
right
um it means that we feel psychologically
safe enough
to raise our hand and say
um
I made a mistake
or I need help
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or I'm scared or I don't know what to do
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather to say these
things with the absolute confidence that
someone on our team will rush to support
us
unfortunately we also all know what it
feels like not to work on a trusting
team where admitting any of those things
could hurt your chances of promotion
could hurt your chances of it you could
be humiliated
and so when we when we work on teams
where leadership is creating an
environment where there's where trust is
a at a premium
we force our people to come to work and
lie hide and fake where they're
pretending that they've made no mistakes
they're lying hiding and faking and
eventually things will crack and things
will eventually break and and when you
talk about reinvention and you talk
about Innovation and you talk about
challenging the status quo or whatever
it is
necessarily there's risk and necessarily
there are mistakes and necessarily
there's stupid ideas and you have to
create an environment which that's good
the alternative is everybody playing it
safe which is not the way that leads to
to best or significant Improvement
there's no such thing as a perfect job
and there's no such thing as a perfect
person of course there are things that
we are doing that hold ourselves back
and of course there are things about the
environment in which we work whether
it's the people or the job or the
whatever the circumstances that may also
be holding us back I mean but to see
ourselves as victims is not is not the
up is not the thing
um but rather to seek opportunity and it
goes back to that growth mindset
um uh which is it's what I've learned is
one of the best ways to grow oneself is
to actually help somebody on the team
grow service you know there's an entire
section in the book shop called
self-help and there's no section of the
Bookshop called help others and I think
what we've done is we've over indexed on
the whole rugged individualism sort of
self-helpy thing how can I be successful
how can I grow my business how can I
lose weight how can I find love and yet
we forget how can I help somebody else
grow their business how can I help
somebody else find success how can I
help help somebody else lose weight and
find love
Etc and the irony is is the more that we
set out to help somebody else because we
have more objectivity with other people
ironically we actually learn to help
ourselves I I tried this out I did a
little experiment
a dear friend of mine was going through
a hard a hard time
a solopreneur
um
the work wasn't going well her marriage
was shaky and she was in a bad place
and so she knows what I do for a living
so she called me up and says would you
spend some time with me I said of course
so every single week religiously we
spent about 90 minutes together she'd
come over and we would talk and I would
offer some
perspective and some ideas and she'd
feel great for like a day or two and
then she'd go back and we'd get together
the next week and she'd feel great for a
couple of days and then go back in this
repeating pattern went on for quite a
while
and then I remember my own work which is
the idea of service
and had a little idea which is to switch
to switch it around and I called her up
and said look I would like some coaching
too and it was genuine I said you know
me better than anybody else I trust you
completely when we get together for one
of our sessions Can it can I can I use
up some of the time can I tell you what
I'm going through
and what ended up happening is we spent
all 90 minutes talking about my stuff
and this went week after week after week
where she was just the uh advice giver
and strange things started to happen she
started to get more stability in her
work more stability to her marriage her
confidence went up and it was because
she was helping me that she was gaining
all the insights and perspective because
it wasn't personalized it's like sales
training and anybody who's ever gone
through sales training you know this
which is you always do it with three
people you know the person who plays the
role of the salesperson the person who
plays the role of the uh the person
you're selling to the buyer and an
observer and it's the Observer that does
the learning not the people playing the
roles well in this case you got to see
herself not being not be uh so close to
it gave her objectivity so I'm a great
believer in if you have a problem to
solve at work try and help somebody else
solve that same problem so there is
another guy who does what I do he writes
books he gives talks Etc his work is
extremely well respected and and I
admire his work as well
I happen to hate him
um he's never he's never done anything
mean to me and we've always had a very
quality relationship when we see each
other professionally I have an arbitrary
hatred of him
and as a result of my hatred I'm
extremely competitive with him
I would log on to Amazon on a regular
basis no and check my book rankings and
then immediately check his
and keep in mind I checked no one else's
Just the Two of Us
and if he was ahead I was angry and if I
was ahead I was smug
and whenever his name came up in polite
conversation I would see underneath
we were invited to speak together at a
conference where we would be interviewed
together
um and I don't mean like like literally
we would be on the stage together and
the interviewer thought it would be fun
if we introduced each other
um
um and so I went first
uh and I turned to him and I said
um you make me really insecure
and I said all of your strengths are all
of my weaknesses and whenever your name
comes up I get really uncomfortable
and he looked at me and he said funny I
think the same thing about you
the reason I was so competitive with him
had nothing to do with him it had
everything to do with me because his
weaknesses revealed to me because his
strength revealed to me my weaknesses
it's more difficult to take a hard look
at myself and say Here's all the work
you have to do it's much easier and dare
I say more fun to to direct all my
energies at beating him
um that turned out to be an extremely
cathartic experience
um and I learned the value of a worthy
rival
and the funny thing is after that
experience I've never checked
mine or his book wrecking since
um I applaud his work celebrate him want
him to do well because it turns out
working together
we actually are stronger
um and I think this is the same Folly in
business right I I like you know which
is we decide who our competitors are
and then we obsess with beating them
like ABC NBC CBS and fox were obsessed
with beating each other and all they did
was look at Nielsen radiations every
morning
and then Netflix came up and didn't like
who cares they're all over the world
because they weren't even looking they
weren't even watching
because that's the arbitrariness of if
you I remember back in the early days
when I first started my career I was in
the ad business and I was Junior dogs
buddy to the junior dog's body and
um I was on the
um competitive analysis team and
basically what that meant was we studied
the competition and we put together
decks to the executives of look what the
competition is doing
and we sometimes would hire outside
Consultants to run you know research for
us and if it was too expensive to study
seven of them we'd cut it down to four
which is hilarious if you think about it
so you're making decisions based on four
and ignore anyway you get my point so
um I think the value of the other
players in your industry of the other
players in the game is not to beat them
because there's no such thing as I said
before you know Best Buy didn't win
anything when Circuit City went bankrupt
um but it's to recognize and respect
them there are some players
who do some or many things better than
you maybe they have a better leadership
stronger culture better marketing maybe
their products are better design who
knows what and instead of trying to beat
them which couldn't mean you choose
underhanded things or just drop your
price
you actually say okay let's make our
product even better they have revealed
our weakness let's Now work on that
because the ultimate the only competitor
in an infinite game is yourself there
are so many lessons that we've learned
over the past year and a half to two
years that I think prepare us to be
ready for the next future
um I got a kick out of during the height
of kovid uh the number of pundits who
said during these unpredictable times I
would smile and say all times are
unpredictable there's never been a time
that was predictable ever
um all that happened was something that
we didn't expect happened that reminded
us that our lives and our work is
unpredictable and to Future proof
ourselves means being ready for the
unpredictable there's something called
an infinite mindset and those with an
infinite mindset Embrace surprise they
find opportunity in the unexpected that
when something goes Haywire they go oh
what could we do with this versus a
finite mindset which likes to exert
control and keep things very very close
and time frame short because they fear
the uncertain they fear anything that's
off the plan and one of the things that
we have to do to Future proof ourselves
is to embrace things that are surprises
and embrace the opportunity in
uncertainty the other thing that I think
we have to learn on how to Future prove
ourselves is how to deal with stress and
how to deal with trauma
um uh whether somebody did well during
covid uh business-wise or whether they
struggle business-wise all of us all of
us suffered some sort of trauma uh and
when I when covet first showed up I
called a friend of mine who's active
duty military and I asked him during
when you're in combat what do you do to
compartmentalize your emotions so you
can stay Mission focused my business
blew up in right in front of me and I
had to focus on my mission of rebuilding
my business I wanted to know how to
control my emotions so I could get the
work done that I had to get done and he
gave me a very sobering warning he said
no one can compartmentalize their
emotions he says we can do it for a
short period of time but every everyone
will suffer the trauma of combat
sometimes many months after we get home
and he said you will go through it
maybe not now but you will go through it
and uh sure sure enough about four or
five months in
um I started to feel extremely off my
game
um and I called him up and I said can I
just ask you you know uh what are your
symptoms when you go through the the the
trauma of combat I asked no leading
questions I simply said what are your
symptoms he said well one I fall out of
my sleep pattern for some reason I go to
bed late for no reason and I don't want
to get up in the morning and I thought
to myself
yep and he said I become unproductive
and I rationalize it like oh you've been
working hard it's okay if you have an
unproductive day or two but then I have
another and another and another and I
thought to myself yep
and he said I also become extremely
anti-social I don't want to talk to
anyone I definitely don't want to ask
for help
and I thought to myself yup
and I realized I was going through
depression I was afraid to use that word
for fear that it sounded like a
diagnosis but it was Little D depression
that's exactly what I was going through
which is why things weren't working and
so I asked my friend again so how do you
overcome it he said one you have to
force yourself to get back into your
sleep pattern and two you have to force
yourself to ask people for help
and that's exactly what I was doing and
I reached out to friends that I trusted
friends that I loved people who I knew
were dispensers of good advice and I
called them one by one and said I'm
going through this what can I do I also
reached out to friends who I knew were
going through similar things and offered
my support for them because that's one
of the things I've learned in my career
which is the best way to solve your
problems is to help people who are going
through the same thing and so to
understand how to react under extreme
stress to understand and build the
relationship so that when you do go
through something you know who to call
my rule during covet and I called all my
a-type personality friends and gave them
my rule which is there's no crying alone
and the question I would ask every one
of you is if you start to cry who are
you going to call
who will you pick up the phone and just
say I need to cry and tell them what's
going on it is much healthier to know
that someone will give you a shoulder
and be there to support you no matter
what you're going through how can we
ensure that we're changing with times
technology culture politics and tastes
um rather than just trying to beat our
competitor and you see it across
Industries uh you know uh publishing for
example
um you know the internet showed up and
they they saw it and they thought it was
nice and they you know as it took on
they sort of I guess they were
interested in it they sort of played
defense and then Amazon showed up and
Amazon went to all of them and said hey
you want to invest in us and they all
said no well now they're all playing
catch up they're all playing defense you
know Netflix went to Blockbuster and
said want to buy us and Blockbuster said
no uh the rest of the TV and movie
industry were too busy comparing who had
higher ratings and they completely
missed the fact that Netflix is now
completely reinvented television I find
that fascinating General Motors was
destroying its own electric vehicles in
a in a to protect its old business and
now they're all rushing to catch up with
Tesla I think this is hilarious and it's
the little companies the Netflix's the
Amazons the Teslas that get ignored that
aren't seen as a threat that end up
defining and redefining entire
marketplaces now this is not unique to
small companies big companies can
absolutely redefine the problem is big
companies are more obsessed with their
finite goals big companies are more
obsessed with beating their competitors
and little companies are obsessed with
their Vision little companies are
obsessed with this outsized Vision that
outstrips the resources they have right
somebody says we're going to do this and
everybody looks around and goes we don't
have the money for that we don't have
the talent for that I guess we'll have
to be creative
and I think this is one of the
opportunities for big companies as they
get big their Visions get smaller they
become goals that they can just do a
back plan for there's nothing inherent
that a big company shouldn't be
Innovative but to your point before they
become risk-averse they become stable
um and at the end of the day it takes
huge Vision what I imagine is a huge
corporation a multi-billion dollar
corporation that someone will say we
imagine a world that's so crazy and so
idealistic that in this large
corporation they all look around and go
we don't have the money for that
we don't have the talent for that I
guess we'll have to be creative
which scares the heck out of
um uh the investor Community but
remember all of those companies were
founded by you know whether it's your
Steve Jobs or all of all these companies
Salesforce they all started by young
people who had no experience and only
had Vision
um and I think that's there's no reason
why big companies cannot uh cannot be
Innovative but I think
it's about pushing their own boundaries
and allowing for entrepreneurship and
inherent in entrepreneurship is
failure you can't experiment without
failing I remember talking to a CFO of a
big company once and he told me that he
has two priorities for the company uh uh
uh Innovation and efficiency
I I said good luck with that you know
there's nothing efficient about
Innovation because you have to keep
trying something over and over again
there's nothing efficient about that and
for some reason I don't know what it is
companies are obsessed with growth
and everybody they brag we're a hyper
Growth Company show me one article not
10 not 15 show me one article that shows
any data that hyper growth is good for
business and good for the company
there is no data to show that companies
are obsessed with growth actually build
stronger companies because they don't
um and so it is a Fool's errand that is
promoted usually by an incentive
structure that rewards short-term
benefits I think what companies can do
is start to look at their incentive
structures and start rewarding things
like teamwork ethics and and long-term
gain and guess what you'll get the
behavior year reward find a friend you
love and uh you know one of those people
who if you called them at three o'clock
in the morning you know they take your
call and you would take theirs
don't do this with a spouse don't do
this with a sibling uh uh don't do this
with a boyfriend or girlfriend those
relationships are too close
um but find a best friend and ask them
this simple question
why are we friends
and they're going to look at you like
you're crazy because it's very hard for
the human brain to put our feelings into
words because the part of the brain that
controls our feelings doesn't control
language this is why we use metaphors
and analogies and why we struggle to
tell people how we actually feel it's
because it's a different part of the
brain and so they're going to look at
you and be like uh
I don't know why are you asking me this
and you say come on I know you've been
there for me uh my whole life and then
you actually stop asking the question
why ironically you actually asked the
question what you say come on what
specifically is it about me that I know
you'd be there for me no matter what and
they're going to hem and haw because
it's hard to put into words don't help
them don't let anybody else help them
and they're going to start describing
you I don't know you're funny you're
smart you're honest you've always been
there for me you go good you play
Devil's Advocate good that's the
definition of a friend what it
specifically is about me that I'd know
you'd be there for me no matter what and
again some will get through this quickly
and some will get through it slowly and
it'll be a struggle and you have to
continue to play Devil's Advocate good
that's the definition of a close friend
what specifically is about me and
eventually they'll give up eventually
they'll stop describing you and they'll
start describing themselves like my
friend said to me Simon I don't know all
I know is that I can sit in a room with
you I don't even have to talk to you and
I feel inspired and I got goosebumps in
fact I'm getting them right now they
will put into words the value you have
in their life and you will have the
emotional reaction you'll either well up
with tears or you will get goosebumps
this puts you in the ballpark this is
where your why lives and if you do this
with multiple friends they will say the
same kind of thing it's in fact
sometimes they'll say the same exact
thing because your why is the thing you
give to the world and amongst your
closest and best friends it is the space
you fill in their lives so that's a fun
little way you can find your Why by
ourselves as individuals we are not very
good we cannot lift heavy weights by
ourselves and we cannot solve complex
Problems by ourselves but in groups we
are remarkable
um and so all of this stuff whether it's
life whether it's whatever your job was
in the service whatever your job is out
of the service whether it's finding a
new job
um whether it's making your way finding
out sort of what your passion is all of
these things are incredibly difficult
they're all incredibly complicated and
the person who thinks that they can
tackle any of these problems by
themselves is a fool plain old you're a
fool you cannot I'm going to tell you
you cannot do it alone and so asking for
help
is perhaps the greatest single thing
anyone can ever learn especially where
everything is new and the stresses are
different and uh and and often feel
overwhelming and scary totally
unfamiliar and the longer you are in the
service
the scarier it is
um because this is you had 15 years
doing one thing knowing one thing
learning a culture and now
not only is it new people don't even
understand what you did and what you
know the military is one of the most
misunderstood cultures in the world it's
so closed and insular that people just
don't know it so you're dealing with
that as well and so to ask for help
in any form
is brilliant I this is the single thing
that
completely transformed my own culture I
had a small business I quit my job and
started my own marketing consultancy a
bunch of years ago and for a few years I
ran on force of personality and it was
great but then if you have a little bit
of a little bit of success force of
Personality doesn't work anymore and all
of a sudden things started crashing on
in around me because I couldn't I
couldn't do it all
and I thought I had to know all the
answers and if I didn't I pretended that
I did because I thought
that's what I had to do and I learned I
learned the very very hard way where I
came it was a dark period that I had to
learn to ask for help and and I it turns
out I was surrounded by people who
wanted to help me they just didn't
because they didn't know I wanted it or
needed it and it was the willingness to
ask for it or accept it that transformed
my life
um and put me on the path that I'm on
now now I'm really open about I can tell
you stuff I'm really good at and I'll
tell you I'm good at that and I'll tell
you I am not good at that I need help
with that if I'm struggling or if I'm
stuck if I'm confused I say can I ask
you I call up friends I call it people
mentors and say I need your help can you
help me and here's what I've learned
about the building of trust we don't
build trust by offering people our help
we build trust by asking people for help
that's what actually creates trust
because it's an expression of
vulnerability right it allows people
us to offer us safety and protection
and that's an act of service for the
other person we always talk about being
a stable company we talk about investing
in stable companies and you know are you
are you stable and you think about
stability stability is is an immobile
object
you know uh and and so uh companies that
are built for stability yes they're able
to weather storms but they don't come
out stronger or better they just come
out they get through building a company
for resilience means that you go into
darkness but you're actually able to
adapt for New Times new technologies new
cultures New Politics new tastes and you
come actually out of the hard times
stronger than you went in
um Victorinox is a great example
Victorinox many of us know them by their
signature product which is the old Swiss
army knife and this company made
basically made a name for themselves on
this basically one line of product and
they had other product but this was this
was the core and then something happened
that they couldn't predict nor could
they uh prepare for which is September
11th happened and overnight we were
banned from taking their product in our
bags
in our hand luggage or in our pockets we
so many of us used to carry a Swiss army
knife in our pockets are just throwing
one on our hand luggage like we all had
one you know every birthday for every
teenager they got at least one right
um every corporate gift you had a couple
of Swiss Army knives and now we were
banned from carrying them which means
you're less likely to buy one to give as
a gift and so their business their
business plummeted overnight
through no fault of their own through no
market conditions nothing predictable
but the genius of Victorinox
is that they were built for resilience
and what they did was they in good times
instead of giving away all the money and
big bonuses in good times they actually
saved a ton of money and their attitude
was
um good times don't last but neither do
bad times and if we want to get through
bad times we need to have we need we
need cash and so instead of panicking
and taking loans or whatever it is they
had their own stack of cash that it that
they'd been hoarding so they had a
little Financial resilience but then
they looked at other products and they
asked their people to help build up and
they started investing heavily in
watches now we have Victorinox watches
which are much more and it's still Swiss
made everything that they could do
everything that they knew how to do
clothing everything they leveraged their
brand heavily and they built it back up
also they protected all of their people
they actually made deals with companies
prior that if bad times ever happened
that that other companies would borrow
their employees which I thought was
genius so they didn't lose their jobs
they just did their job somewhere else
and they completely reinvented their
company company now to this day their
Swiss army knife never really recovered
it came up back a bit but it's now not
the major product as a minor product
that they sell because they actually
came out stronger and reinvented and to
be able to do that think about that
coming in as one kind of company and
coming out of another kind of company
very very rare and very very special but
very infinite minded I think some people
turn off the humanity when they go to
work
um you know they they they may be you
know loving parents and loving friends
and loving you know children to their
own parents and yet for some reason
there's a switch that they think that
that's irresponsible to do at work now
I'm not talking about necessarily
wearing your heart on your sleeve every
day there is something called emotional
professionalism you know if you're
having a bad day you can say listen I'm
a little off my game today but you can't
sit in the meeting with your arms folded
and be grumpy and give one word answers
that's that's emotionally unprofessional
you know you can have hard feelings but
you can't go around screaming and
yelling at people you know you can have
um so I think there's a there's
emotional professionalism but I think
for some reason especially as people
make their way up the ranks
um they think that expressing any kind
of emotion is a sign of weakness
um even that word vulnerability we talk
you know it's such a common word now
being talked about in in the business
world that you have to be vulnerable to
this day it makes some people feel very
uncomfortable I don't want to be
vulnerable well all vulnerability means
um is saying things like I don't know or
I need help or I'm overwhelmed or can
you you know can you help me do this
because I don't know how to do this or
I've been promoted to a position where
maybe I need more training and the
reason we're afraid of saying that is
for fear that it makes us look weak
which will then damage our careers the
reality is the total opposite by saying
I don't know means someone can help us
but instead we choose to lie hide and
fake very often which eventually gets
revealed enough stress piled on on that
lying hiding and faking collapses either
professionally or personally either we
either feel the stress or or the
projects that we're working on start to
go haywire and very often when we get to
those points everybody knows anyway
um and uh the amazing thing that I've
learned is when you say can somebody
help me
um we're surrounded by people who would
love to help us they just didn't think
we needed it because we acted as if we
didn't so I think a large part of it is
is quite frankly fear fear that if I
express these things that'll that people
will think I'm not qualified for my job
um uh where the the uh the the the
opposite is true and remember when you
are in a position of leadership you
don't actually have to be better at
doing the job that the people you lead
you have to be responsible for taking
care of them to make sure they're good
at their job but for some reason we
think that
um I have to be better than you at your
own job because I'm the leader
completely false I just have to make
sure that you're equipped you have the
tools the training and the psychological
safety to come to be the best you can be
even if it's better than me one of the
things that um we we do is um is is we
is creating a cult culture in which
people understand that the reason we're
giving feedback is not to quote unquote
criticize them but to help them grow as
human beings and that has to be that has
to be established like this this is what
we're gonna the advice I I offer is it's
not just a checklist that you do and
everything goes fine you know you create
a culture in which uh difficult
conversations and uh and and critical
feedback are welcomed or at least
understood
um but it's also how we give it um
usually we give it by pulling out a
piece of paper and pointing out the
thing that's wrong
um and you know and saying you've got to
fix something right we usually point to
the evidence first
um as opposed to starting by with by by
the human being which is you know
there's stuff I want to share with you I
don't know where what it means but I
wanted to raise it with you in case
there is an issue
um because I care about you and I want
to see that you grow here but there's
some evidence that things are going a
little sideways and I want to I want to
address them with them to see what
opportunities there are or if there's
anything wrong because I don't know the
reasons behind it but
um here's what
um for example the way you talked to
your teammates the other day was a
little harsh and ordinarily I'd be
wanting to say oh you know you're having
a bad day it's no problem you know
everybody gets a everybody gets a bad
day but you've been really beating up on
people
um I don't even know if you're aware of
that right
um uh and sometimes they'll say I'm
having a hard time and it opens up or
they'll say I wasn't even aware I didn't
even know or it reveals something as
opposed to saying stop yelling at people
nobody wants to work for you if all you
do is yell at people you know it's hard
for people to receive and so good
feedback is not just about conveying the
point we're trying to make it's about
creating a condition in which the person
is more likely to listen and hear it so
we're all proud of ourselves once we've
told them we did you did you give her
the feedback yeah I told her right did
they hear the feedback uh different
question I think one of the essential
skills of being a good coach is
listening and this is a skill that is
not taught in school we don't learn it
on Home unfortunately and and we don't
learn it at work
listening is not hearing the words that
are spoken that's like my favorite quote
that you say go ahead I'm sorry
listening is
I thought I was being original
the the listening listening is not about
hearing the words that are spoken it's
not being able to Parrot back what
somebody said to you listening is
listening for meaning right
um you uh uh you are a good listener
the test for being good a listener is if
the other person feels heard
right say that again right write that
down so so I mean we've all had we just
take it out of the context of business
right we've all had an argument or
wanted to share our feelings with a
friend or a loved one right spouse
girlfriend boyfriend you're sitting on
the couch and you say something's
bugging you and you say can I just tell
you something that's bugging me and they
respond by trying to fix it or they
respond by pointing out the facts that
may or may not align with how you feel
right well that's impossible because
this is what happened and what they're
missing is you are not looking for them
you're not looking for them to compare
the facts of what's being said you just
want to feel heard you just want
somebody to go oh my God that's really
hard yeah I hear it I hear that thank
you for sharing that with me that must
be difficult
that's all I needed right I'll give you
a a a a very funny example of bad
listening so I used to date a girl who's
an air traffic controller air attractive
controllers are a breed unto themselves
and it's only about the facts and I woke
up one morning I had something in my eye
and I couldn't open my eye it was
hurting and I'm like flushing it out
with water and nothing's work and I mean
I couldn't even open my eyes to have her
come on like come here come here I'm
gonna look in my eye what do you see
anything do you understand anything and
she looks in she goes like this and she
goes there's nothing there and then
walks away
and I eventually you know whatever it
was I eventually was okay and I went up
to her I was like
WTF right
I'm like I had something in my eye you
just walked away
and she's like there was nothing there
so what do you want me to do
I was like a little sympathy she's like
well that's not going to get anything
out of your eye
listening is standing by my side while
I'm flushing it out with water and go oh
my God that must hurt so much yeah it
does thank you right that's listening
and if somebody can learn to listen and
now now this is where it gets actionable
this is not me just waxing philosophical
and telling funny stories about
listening my friend will guderro do how
many of you are
or restaurant people have you ever heard
of 11 Madison Park so at some point in
New York City 11 Madison Park was the
best rest restaurant in the world right
ranked number one and will believes in
this he's he was the former owner he
believes in this concept of unreasonable
Hospitality which is going to what good
services and then going way way way
Beyond and one of the core tenets of
unreasonable hospitality is learning to
listen and I'll give you an example that
directly impacts your business most
agents don't listen
and I'll give you an example what do you
do what do you do for your clients after
they close on a home right it's very
common we've all we've we've all bought
a home too right which is you walk into
this new home that you just bought as a
buyer and there's a bottle of champagne
in the fridge
there's a basket of flowers on the
dining room table
the same basket of flowers that you gave
to every other client the same bottle of
champagne that you gave to every client
generic I'm a number it's just it's just
rote but if you were listening
while they were looking at all those
homes and they saw this one little room
that was too small to make a bedroom it
was just sort of a stupid little Nook
that nobody really understood why that
room existed in the house and your
client walked and goes I could make this
my yoga room and that's the house they
bought instead of putting a bottle of
champagne in the house this is what will
talks about instead of putting a bottle
of champagne in the fridge why not put a
yoga mat in that room
with a little note that says it's
perfect right
that's called listening and every single
time you go out
every single time you go out with
clients
uh
they are telling you things they're
telling you stories they're waxing
philosophical they're telling you what
they don't like and what they do like
but the problem is you're listening to
whether they like big Windows you're
listening to whether they like the view
you're listening to whether they have
two cars and they need three cars or
whatever it is but you're not listening
to the reasons why the why you're not
listening for the meaning and that's
those are the little notes you want to
make that make someone feel seen and
make someone feel heard I had the
opportunity to work with the Navy Seals
and within the Navy Seals there's
actually a more Elite group within the
seals that's much harder to get into you
have to be a seal for like five years
before you even can get into this even
more Elite group and I asked the
director of training for this group you
know how do you choose who gets into
this more Elite group within your own
within your own culture and he drew uh
an XY access he drew a a graph for me
um uh and on the vertical axis he wrote
performance and on the horizontal axis
he wrote trust the way they Define
performance is how good are you at your
job right your skill set uh the way they
Define trust is what kind of person are
you and the way they put it is I may
trust you with my money I mean trust you
with my life but do I trust you with my
money and my wife's right so
so uh clearly nobody wants a low
performer of low trust clearly clearly
everybody wants the high performer of
high Trust on their team clearly they
learn
is that a high performer of low trust is
actually a toxic team member and they
would rather have a medium performer of
high trust sometimes a low performer pie
trust it's a relative scale over the
high performer of low trust and this is
one of the highest performing
organizations on the planet and they put
huge uh Credence in the trustworthiness
and the character of the team member
over their simple uh performance metrics
in business we're the opposite we have a
million metrics to measure someone's
performance and we have negligible to no
metrics to measure someone's trust and
so you may have a selfish driven toxic
team member who if they're high
performing what do we do we promote them
and sometimes you get to the point where
leadership knows that this person is
toxic and you say you know you probably
shouldn't do something about this you
maybe want to remove them from the team
and they say the same thing they're like
yeah I know the performance is so good
you're literally just waiting for
something to collapse meaning either
other people will leave or the culture
will start to crack or there's a scandal
or that person will leave because they
get a better job offer they're not loyal
so they may be your highest performer
but they're not loyal
um with the what the seals learn
uh is sometimes these these medium
performers of high trust are your best
natural uh uh best natural leaders the
irony is you know if you go to any team
it's actually really easy to find these
toxic team members that's the irony even
though we don't formally measure it go
to any team and ask them who the [ __ ]
is and they'll all point to the same
person okay
um uh and and and and that that's an
opportunity to coach them I don't
believe in firing them I believe in
coaching them you let people go when
they're proved to be uncoachable and by
the way if you go to that same team you
say who do you trust more than anybody
else who's got your back no matter what
who's always who's always there to help
you they're probably also point to the
same person who might be your best
natural leader and they may not be your
best individual performer we don't teach
difficult conversations we don't teach
conflict resolution we don't teach
de-escalation and we don't teach how to
give and receive feedback we don't teach
how to treat ideas we don't even teach
people how to have a meeting
like we don't teach any of these things
and so we're just leaving it up to
chance to hope that somebody knows what
they're doing which we would never let
somebody on the front line do we give
them tons of training on how to do their
jobs so part of it is is is the skill
set that we that we can train
um the other thing is a lot of leaders I
think are afraid of doing things for
fear of saying the wrong thing and again
this this really lends itself to the
training we need to give our leaders and
especially I think this was really
exaggerated after the murder of George
Floyd
um where so many leaders did nothing
they're not bad people they were just so
afraid of saying the wrong thing or
inflaming a situation or triggering
someone that they chose to to just do
nothing
um and so one of the things we need to
do is teach people how to lean into
tension
um uh and and to learn how to
de-escalate one's own anger or or one's
own trigger and again you brought it up
before which is and replace it with
curiosity tell me more what else I'm
struggling to under stand let me tell
you the story that's going through my
head I think is a really big one that
I've learned which is because I'm
reacting based on my own narrative right
and so they're reacting to my words or
my reaction and so one of the things
that's really helped me is to share
what's going on in my head so that
people have the context of where my
reaction is coming from let me let me
tell you what my history is and what my
background is I'm not saying this is
right or wrong I'm just telling you my
story and I'll say I had this happen in
the past where X Y and Z and so I'm
nervous at your suggestion because in
the past this has happened can you help
me resolve this or do you understand
where I'm coming from
and I think the more we can share what's
going on in the process rather than
simply you know responding with our
answers or our reactions helps the other
person see the way we're trying to see
it and it also encourages us to see the
way they're trying to see it so I think
the more we share it's that
vulnerability word again right let me
tell you my history let me tell you my
baggage let me tell you my background
let me tell you my experiences let me
tell you where my opinion is coming from
um the worst thing the one that drives
me up the wall the one that triggers me
is this is how we've always done it well
why do we do it that way because this is
how we've always done it and my rule is
if you cannot tell me why we're doing it
this way that means it's it's on the
chopping block that doesn't mean it has
to change but but I wanna I want real
explanations of why we do something this
way if somebody can't tell me then then
then it's it's open to being changed
I'll give you a personal example the
person who's who sold me this property
uh it was the seller's agent oh okay
right he was charming and nice and
wonderful and lovely and helpful and all
the things that I would expect and I
warmed up to him and he was
apparently helping me and then I
remember distinctly at the closing
he sat there with no personality all of
his charm had left
all his friendliness had gone he barely
engaged with me he just wanted to be
there to collect his checks he could get
out of there
and I realized it was all fake it was
all for show it was all to butter me up
so that I would simply sign on the
dotted line and as a result I will never
work with him again as a buyer or a
seller
I'll never list with him ever and I
probably will never work with that
company again because I realized they
just saw me as a number they never saw
me as a person in the first place
um he was an old white guy I mean that
should tell you a little bit of
something as well that that sort of
maybe how he was raised in the industry
um and by the way the mortgage broker
was no different you know uh he was
charming and wonderful and lovely and
helped me get a great rate etc etc and
then I remember after I closed he called
me and said congratulations and I said
oh thank you that's so nice of you and
he called me just to congratulate me on
closing on my house and then the first
thing he said to me was and if you know
anybody who's looking for a mortgage I'd
really appreciate the recommendation he
never called me to congratulate me he
called me because he wanted the referral
like give it a breath
you know like call me and congratulate
me and a week later asked me for the
referral and see let me tell you what
sucks about that can I say that what
sucks about that totally is that's
that one person yeah colored your entity
and but this is finite versus infinite
okay he he could only see the
transaction he could only see get
business get more business get business
get more business what he didn't
understand is he's dealing with a human
being and the more there's a
relationship I will gladly recommend him
I will gladly introduce you to my guy
right
um now I'm completely agnostic because
if you're going to treat me like a
transaction I'm going to treat you like
a transaction if you're going to treat
me like a transaction I'm going to
squeeze you to get more money out of you
I want a lower rate I'm going to squeeze
the agents but if you treat me like a
human being I'll gladly pay a higher
rate because I want to work with you and
that's what infinite minded players
understand better which you don't have
to be the cheapest you don't have to
have the lowest rate or the lowest price
if you have a great relationship what
does it mean to live an infinite life
clearly our lives are finite we're born
we die we come we go
but life is infinite
The Game of Life will continue with us
or without us
which means every single one of us has a
choice
we don't get to choose the nature of the
game Life is infinite we don't even get
to choose if we want to play in the game
or night once you're born you're in it
we get one choice
do you want to play with a finite
mindset
but you want to play with an infinite
mindset to play with a finite mindset
means waking up every day and say I'm
going to be the best I'm going to be
better than everybody else
I'm going to accumulate more power more
responsibility more money whatever it is
whatever whatever your metric is
I'm gonna I'm gonna get more than
anybody else me
and when you die you take none of it
with you
or we can choose to live our lives with
an infinite mindset
which means I'm going to leave this
world the school in better shape than I
found it it means I'm going to devote my
life to see that those around me rise
and we know that we're living with an
infinite mindset because our obsession
is seeing that we have an impact on the
lives of the people around us
we've all had teachers and some of you
are those teachers we're 20 or 30 years
from now I can go to one of your
students and say you're a remarkable
human being you've accomplished so much
in your life how did you become the
person you are today and they will tell
me your name
we all remember the teacher who believed
in us we all remember the teacher who
had our backs we all remember the
teachers saw something in us that nobody
else saw we've forgotten all the others
but we remember those couple
and that's what it means to live with an
infinite mindset it means we divert
ourselves to that mindset for everyone
in our lives that other teachers will
say that about us other principles will
say that about us other students will
say that about us our friends will say
that about us I am who I am today
because of you and I will commit to live
the same life that you taught me how to
live and you will literally live on
beyond your own lifestyle your own
lifetime
that when you're gone others will carry
your work
for you
this is what it means to live an
infinite life and it is just
a choice I try and read uh news from
both sides of the political aisle not to
find the one I agree with but I want to
understand how it's being reported I
want to know the different narratives
that are being told so that I can
understand those narratives so I can
speak to those narratives I can learn
those narratives and find hypocrisy in
both sides by the way
um I think that the one the one mistake
that we all fall into is to decide that
the ones that I agree with are right and
the ones that I disagree with are wrong
and this this binary notion of right
versus wrong
um is is what's gotten us into this into
this mess in the first place
um life is not so so so so so black and
white in no respect uh it's nuanced and
gray and complicated and messy and to to
understand that we are hypocrites in our
own opinions
um and so is the other side and simply
pointing out the hypocrisy of the other
side is of no help whatsoever what's
more important is supporting that our
own hypocrisy and to try and understand
that like I said it's a worthy rivalry
thing right it's not trying to dominate
or be right but it's rather tried to
improve and to grow
um and and so one of the things that I
default to our values
um I'm very proud of the fact that some
of my friendships are with people who
have very very very different uh
political points of view
um who we voted very very differently in
political elections
um and we can go to blows uh talking
about some of the things that the
government is is deciding whether we
agree or disagree with it
um but at the end of the day their
values are like mine and we and we
believe in taking care of each other and
we believe in looking out for each other
and at the end of the day more than
their politics they're my friend and I
learned this lesson the hard way where I
was walking uh I was going for a walk
with a friend who has very different
political views than me and she said
something and I I definitely thought it
and I fear I may have said it how can
you be so stupid
and I realized I just called my friend
stupid and she completely got angry at
me not because I disagreed with her it's
because I judged her and insulted her
and she you know what she was a hundred
percent right
and what I had to learn in that moment
was to listen
was to replace my judgment with
curiosity
and to understand where her point of
view comes from and that I and that the
more Curious I became to understand that
there were actually things that we did
agree upon and though we may not have
agreed upon everything we actually could
find common ground and that Common
Ground always boiled down to our values
and the more that I got good at
listening to her she actually we became
much more open to listening to me
and so as opposed to me hammering my
opinion at her we started to have
conversations and so I think when you go
to a values level politics becomes
secondary but when we let go of our
values then all we have is the politics
which is upsetting a just cause is
something a lot more idealistic it's a
statement of the world that you wish the
the way the world you wished it worked
the the world that you imagine like we
imagine a world as PWC we imagine a
world in which
and then we devote our practice we
devote our energy we devote our
resources to advance towards that cause
and we're going to bring our clients
with us the work that we do takes us
closer to that quote so I'll give you an
example so my just cause our
organizations just cause we imagine a
world so you can see there's that
Forward Thinking which as an aside which
is why we call it vision is because you
have to be able to see it right so we
imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired
feel safe wherever they are and end the
day fulfilled by the work that they do
that is our cause that is a cause so
just that we would be willing to
sacrifice in order to advance closer
towards that ideal we will never get
there it is an ideal okay and you can
look at organizations or leaders that
have made profound impact in their
Industries or in the world you'll see
these just causes whether it's all men
are created equal right it's a just
cause imperfect in all in its own way
but you can see a nation striving
um I have a dream literally imagining
that one day little black children will
hold hands on the playground with little
white children imperfect in its own uh
in in reality but you can see a a nation
striving
um when Apple and Steve Jobs used to
talk about empowering individuals to
stand up to Big Brother you can see the
attraction to the personal computer
because it literally gives power to an
individual to compete against a
corporation imperfect but a striving and
all of these things become striving that
become incredibly inspiring for for a
Workforce because they feel like they're
contributing to something bigger than
themselves but when you think about
innovation
if you say provide greater value for our
clients
and it's not wrong I have to stress it's
not wrong
but but
when you say innovate around that The
Innovation tends to be more features and
benefits it tends to be tweaking and
efficiencies when you say be the best I
don't even know how you innovate around
that right you can't say some to say
somebody
you know make innovate so we're better
but when you say Innovative way to
advance this the ideas can come from
anywhere inside the organization and the
ideas tend to be a lot bigger okay so
it's not that those things are wrong
that what I'm what I'm offering are what
a a clearer path to embracing an
infinite mindset okay right it's not
that the other doesn't work it doesn't
have value it just has less value in the
infinite game I was uh during covid
um I worked out with a friend of mine
who lives somewhere else we worked out
on FaceTime together we would just turn
on FaceTime and just do the same workout
together basically and one day we were
doing a particularly difficult workout
and I said to her I have some good news
and I have some bad news she says well
what's the bad news I said the bad news
is we're only halfway done she says well
what's the good news I said the good
news is we're already halfway done
and that simple the simple way in which
I present the information literally
profoundly changes the way in which we
do the second half of the the workout
we're only halfway done the rest of the
the workout's a slog it's difficult it's
hard and we don't want to do it we're
already halfway done I mean it's all
downhill we've already done this once we
can easily finish this off and it's
amazing how easy it is to change our
mindset
um uh uh and so it's the same thing here
um we've done it in our own organization
where um we see another organization who
you know I mean I hate to use the word I
use it just for the for the example but
outpaces us I mean we don't care about
that but and and instead of getting all
angry and hot and bothered and trying to
beat them we say to them we're the
arrival what what you know what strength
do they have that's revealing a weakness
in us and we're like oh my goodness our
website sucks or our e-commerce sucks or
our you know customer service sucks or
whatever it is you know we spend a lot
of time looking at people who we admire
who are in our space who do some or many
things better than us we like look at
their websites we look at their product
we look at the ease of use we're like
wow that's really good you know we don't
have to like it we don't have to agree
with it but we can still complement it
and I think that's the big thing people
think that you know that you you know uh
that you have to hate everything that
somebody does nonsense you don't have to
agree or like but you do have to respect
um and uh and quite frankly to put on
blinders and go through the world with
blinders on that there's no one else out
there and they definitely can't do
anything better than you is quite
frankly just stupid because it's just
not true
um you're not great at everything and
you never will be it's an infinite game
it's a game of constant Improvement just
like every person there's no such thing
as a perfect person you know we should
be in a growth mindset constantly trying
to improve every day of Our Lives it's
the same thing and it's even that's
difficult even that's you even that you
can't you can't grow every day even
that's hard you know it's messy and
human and that's the fun and that's why
you go back to trusting teams and why
the teamwork matters so much because
sometimes we can beat up ourselves or
get stuck in a negative mindset and all
you need is one person to walk up and be
like hey worthy rival right
so the nice thing about worthy Rivals is
it's subjective you can choose whichever
person whichever company you want you
don't have internal competition but you
can have attorney work internal Rivals
you know where there are other people
that you compare yourselves to and
you're trying to get better
um uh but you don't want to stab each
other in the back get angry when
somebody else gets a promotion like
we've all had that we've all had that
you know deep down inside we see when
somebody gets a promotion when we didn't
right
um even if we weren't even up for it
um uh that's that's a that's a sign
where necessary change needs to happen
uh in our mindset uh it's easier to do
than you think and when you get in the
habit of it it's absolutely wonderful
tell someone I need help like I think it
is one of us it's one of these skills
that is becoming fast lost especially
amongst a younger generation which is
the skill to ask for help you know we're
all trying to act so tough you know this
this nation over indexed on the whole
rugged individualism thing you know
where we Define successes visual success
um and and most of our metrics most of
our incentives and almost every job are
individual incentives there you know
there's no team bonus there's an
individual bonus if you hit your numbers
you know
um and uh I think we've we've overdid it
quite frankly uh and I think it's the
pendulum needs to come back uh and and
and we have to remember that we're a
team we're members of teams we're
members of families remember communities
or members of societies and this is
where maslov got it wrong you know
Maslow's hierarchy of needs he says you
know fundamentally at the bottom of the
pyramid is food and shelter
um and he put you know third you know
third up the rung he put a a uh
relationships well I've never heard of
anyone Dying by suicide because they
were hungry I've heard of people talking
about suicide because they were lonely
so in other words it can't be right and
at the top you have self-actualization
how or like I'm all self-actualized
looking down with the rest of you who
aren't at the top of the period what
about shared actualization you know and
the mistake he made is that there's a
paradox which is every moment of every
day we are both individuals and members
of groups and every day we have to
reconcile that do I put myself first at
the expense of someone else or do I
prioritize someone else at the expense
of myself
and the answer is you're right you're
wrong and there's a whole group of
people that says no no you always take
care of yourself first because if you're
not healthy you can't help others and
there's another group of people that
says no you always help others first
because unless you help them they won't
be there for you it's a paradox it
doesn't work it's not so clean
um and this is what we have to reconcile
every day and this is why finding
balance and managing it and the stresses
and trains but the the challenge of
asking for help and relying on our
community really really matters my my
definition of faith is that knowing
you're on a team even when you don't
know who all the players are
um we are surrounded by people who love
us and will take care of us you just
have to ask sometimes because sometimes
they don't know that we need it how do
we replace our judgment with curiosity
um so there's a simple technique there
are simple techniques to do this um one
is write yourself a little reminder put
a little sticky on your computer that
says be curious or ask questions you'd
be amazed how well that works but
especially in times when we're judging
uh especially when we're in groups of
leaders we're in meetings you know we
can snowball into judgment really
quickly let's say someone's performance
is in Decline immediately they're lazy
you know they're stupid they don't
understand they're a problem child
um all it takes is one person to break
that judgment and say well maybe they're
going through something and there is a
technique where when you believe when
you start to form a narrative about
someone or about something that you
force yourself to come up with 21
possible Alternatives of what could be
going on in their life so are they lazy
absolutely that's absolutely a
possibility are they a problem child are
they toxic absolutely are they going
through is are there kids struggling at
school maybe or do they have problems in
their family maybe someone's sick maybe
do they have medical issues that they're
hiding from us that that they're too
embarrassed about maybe like my point is
is can you go through the exercise of
writing 20 or 21 alternative stories of
what could be happening and all of a
sudden we find ourselves talking about
and treating that person differently and
it doesn't just come about people it's
also about decisions we're making at
work and all again in a meeting all it
takes is one person to raise a question
of what if
um and uh as Leaders The more we start
uh asking each other and ourselves what
if or what are the opportunities what
are the possibilities we'll find
ourselves doing that with our people
um that when they come to us instead of
us correcting them and telling that
they're wrong raising questions but
believe it or not simply having a little
reminder to be curious is is really
important first and foremost we have to
understand that there's no such thing as
certainty of outcome
um and this is why this is one of the
this is a huge difference between finite
mindsets and infinite mindsets right a
finite-minded leader is afraid of
surprises and does not like uncertainty
which is why they like to work work in
very short time frames because you can
actually affect quite a lot of certainty
if you only think quarter to quarter
maybe year to year but if you start
thinking in five and ten year increments
you we all know we have zero control
over those outcomes so finite minded
players like to play with very short
time frames because it makes them feel
better even though the game is infinite
so it's actually again sort of a stupid
idea
um infinite-minded players Embrace
uncertainty and find opportunity in
Surprise and so where something goes
wrong or different and just as an aside
I got such a kick out of when covet
struck you know everybody was talking
about during these uncertain times
newsflash all times are uncertain
there's never been a time in history
ever that was certain all that happened
was something that we didn't expect took
place that reminded us that time is
uncertain and for the finite minded
players the immediate reaction was Panic
right
um what am I going to do how am I going
to survive and try and double down on
the old way of doing things hoping that
if I just did it more or at least
attempt to do it online that I would
that it would survive right the more
infinite minded players and this has
nothing to do with stress we can still
have high stress with the with with what
was going on but the more infinite
minded players saw the sudden change in
their business and saw and thought Oh
okay this is an opportunity what can I
do with this
and instead of doubling down on the way
they used to do things but doing it
online they said okay the times have
changed the way I operate my business
have changed all the things that I used
to be able to do like having lunch with
people can't do anymore
so given what I know now if if I was
starting from scratch I have something
really valuable and important how would
I build my business today to still
provide the value to the people who are
looking for the thing that I offer
and that was their mentality their
mentality was very entrepreneurial their
mentality was very creative
um and they though it may have caused
stress there was an appreciation for the
opportunity one of the nice things about
the infinite game is two players or more
who sell basically the same product for
basically the same price for basically
the same quality can all be wildly
successful at the same time like no one
wins
um and and remember we're deciding the
metrics so we could decide that it's
market share or revenue or profit and
we're making these arbitrary comparisons
to arbitrary other players and we can be
all high and mighty about ourselves you
know General Motors decided that um that
market share was the thing and they were
obsessed with being number one in market
share meanwhile they were losing money
hand over fist year after year after
year not sure if that's a very uh
infinite minded Focus uh because you're
clearly going to put yourself out of the
game remember when when Circuit City
went bankrupt Best Buy didn't win
anything
um if anything they had to change the
way that they played because Amazon
became a much more dominant force in the
industry and so they couldn't actually
do the things that they used to do and
this is what it means to be an infinite
player means you understand that it's
not simply about repeating the same
thing that's always worked but it's
adapting with politics and culture and
technology and it's not actually about
competing against another player on in
the field but the only true competitor
in an infinite game is actually yourself
how do I make my product better this
year than it was last year how do I give
better advice this year than I gave last
year how to become a better leader this
year than I was than I was last year and
it's a constant constant education of
constant constant Improvement I can tell
you a funny story which uh you'll
recognize from the book which really
captures the difference between a finite
and infinite mindset and it comes from a
personal experience
I had the opportunity to speak at an
education Summit for Microsoft and then
a few months later I was asked to speak
in an education Summit for Apple now
this was back in the Steve Ballmer days
when Steve Ballmer ran men ran Microsoft
um and at the Microsoft Summit the vast
majority of the executives spent the
vast majority of their presentations
talking about how to beat Apple
Balmer at the time was obsessed with
beating Apple
um at the Apple Summit a hundred percent
of the executives spent a hundred
percent of their presentations talking
about how to help teachers teach and how
to help students learn one was obsessed
with their mission the other one was
obsessed with beating their competition
um guess which one was struggling with
issues of trust cooperation and
innovation
um so at the end of my uh talk at
Microsoft they gave me a gift they gave
me the new Zune when it was a thing this
was Microsoft's response to the iPod
and again there's plenty of uh evidence
and footage of Balmer talking about he
was going to beat the iPod and this was
going to be the best product ever and I
have to say this little piece of
technology was quite good it was very
user friendly it was it worked very well
it was it was it was a really nice
little product
um at the end of my Apple talk I was
sharing a taxi with a senior Apple
executive and I couldn't help myself I
happened I just had to stir the pot uh
so I I turned to him and I said you know
Microsoft gave me their new Zune and it
is so much better than your iPod touch
and he turned to me and he said I have
no doubt
and the conversation was over
because an infinite player understands
sometimes you have the better product
sometimes they have the better product
sometimes you're ahead and sometimes
you're behind uh the goal is not to beat
your competitor the goal is to outdo
yourself
where Microsoft was obsessed with
beating apple apple ignored Microsoft
and was obsessed with out doing itself
uh a year later Apple introduced the
iPhone which rendered both the iPod and
the Zune completely obsolete one of the
things we have to remember is that just
because the business can function with a
distributed Workforce with an online
Workforce we know that there's a
sacrifice you know it's harder to build
trust you know if you if you've joined
the company during covid you've never
physically met any of your your
colleagues or co-workers you know and
you know it's much harder to build trust
when we don't meet each other we take
for granted that we go to the office
that you know the little brief
interactions we have at work where you
walk past somebody in the hall and say
hello or the talk going into the meeting
and the talk coming out of the meeting
and bumping into somebody getting oh I
meant to tell you something or do you
want to grab a coffee know one of these
things by themselves does anything but
over the course of time they contribute
to the building of trust to the building
of Human Relationships in an online
context we don't have any of the
in-between all we have is the meeting we
log on WE log off that's it and so what
a lot of companies
um um haven't recognized is that
building Trust online is possible but it
actually requires more work what used to
happen just relatively organically now
has to be now has to happen
prescriptively
so for example
um I'm a huge fan of the Monday morning
huddle we do one on our team we're on
Monday morning the whole team comes
together
um and it's there's no discussion of
work or deadlines or workloads or
anything it's a human call where we
simply say what's on your heart and mind
and then we answer some funny or
poignant question that's posed To Us by
the person who's leading the Huddle that
month
um and and we simply talk about
ourselves and you learn a lot about
somebody you know somebody will say oh I
had a great weekend with my kids and we
went you know we went hiking I didn't
even know that they had kids you know or
somebody will say to be honest it was a
really hard weekend
um my father has cancer and he's in the
hospital and he took a turn for the
worst and uh and we start to see each
other as human and we start to empathize
and we start to create relationship
and we start to get to know each other
but it's done prescriptively it we we
make it happen
um I'm also a huge fan of of turning on
a zoom for example and just working like
we're not actually working with each
other we're just in each other's screens
as we're getting our own work done it's
nice to have somebody there I'm also
believing about a huge fan of the
telephone
um you know zooms are tiring especially
when you have them all day
um you know it's fake uh you know very
often you know I'm looking at a DOT at
the top of my screen so that you'll
think I'm making eye contact with you
but really I'm just staring at the dot
at the top of my screen or if I'm
staring at you sometimes the placement
of the camera in the screens what you
see is this but I'm looking right at
your eyes you know
um and so I think a telephone believe it
or not is actually a much better way to
connect with somebody especially when
someone's distracted when you can see
that someone's doing email you know
while you're talking there's no actual
polite way to say can you stop doing
that and listen to me please you know
and we just sort of
do it on the telephone if you hear
someone's distracted you go hello you
there they go sorry sorry you know you
can actually catch people
and I find that those interactions you
know I'm a Pacer I like to Pace when I'm
on the phone when I'm thinking I can't
Pace on Zoom which means my thinking is
junk right when I'm on a phone call I
can walk around and I can walk around
wherever I go and I can talk to somebody
and I can be much more engaged I think
we especially for sales people
use the phone pick up the phone how are
you wanted to check in with you you know
have a conversation without Zoom uh I
actually think it's actually much better
for building relationship believe it or
not having zooms occasionally is great
too but I think we've under we've
forgotten we've forgotten how good the
phone is the tension is healthy the
tension is good
um you know if all you have is empathy
then you have a hippie commune and
you're not actually gonna cure anything
but if all you're doing is driving the
numbers driving the numbers uh you're
gonna have a short life span and break
the machine also and you might have a
spike and then you'll disappear
or all your best people say I I hate it
here and they go work somewhere else and
take all of their their their their
Brilliance somewhere else
um so you there is a balance but there's
also a hierarchy you know it's not 50
50. there's no such thing as 50 50. it
doesn't exist you can't say well we're
50 driven by performance and 50 driven
by culture because you will face
decisions where one of those things has
to we'll suck sacrifice the other the
which one the question is which one are
you going to choose there has to be a
bias towards people there has to be a
bias towards uh the teamwork the
environment
um and the will to to succeed is driven
by the belief in the cause
um uh uh you know if if if the cause is
clear and the metrics and you're letting
people see the metric so they feel they
feel like we're making progress again go
back to that Marathon analogy right
which is you're exhausted you're tired
but you're getting close to the Finish
Line you start running faster not slower
that's a good point
um uh and so uh it's it's it's keeping
people included to know what the metrics
mean and um and which ones are trending
and which ones are absolute but yeah
there's nothing wrong with the drive to
succeed as long as there's a context
within which uh within which that drive
exists when we are willing to put
ourselves at risk to be there for
someone right don't worry if this goes
south I will be there for you
um which may mean working late it may
mean working extra hours it may be
putting our reputations on the line I
mean there's a lot of things that that
takes
um but when we genuinely promise to be
there for someone
um
um uh and and it has to be genuine uh
because if it gets tested it's it's very
easy to find out if it was genuine or
not
um but if it's genuine then then it's
repaid remarkably let me give you a
silly example
um let's say that um so I talk about
this um sometimes which is the giving of
time and energy is more powerful than
the giving of money you can't build
trust with money so paying somebody
bonuses and giving somebody a big salary
though feels nice is not earning or
building any trust whatsoever you cannot
pay for trust
um and here's the example
um let's say you're moving house
um and one of your friends says you know
what I want to help you we've been
friends for years
um I'm gonna pay for the moving van
here's five thousand dollars and the
moving van let me know how it goes have
a great move that's really generous
right
another friend says you know what I want
to help you move and they come over the
week before and they're sitting in your
house packing boxes they're
sweat dripping down their brow they're
there with you all day they're there to
help load the truck they're there to
help unload the truck they're they're
there
um uh to unwrap everything right they
paid zero money
they give you time and energy which are
non-redeemable Commodities money we make
money we spend money we make money back
it's a redeemable commodity time and
energy are non-redeemable Commodities
and so when someone gives us something
that they cannot get back
it has a much more powerful effect on
how we feel so now both those people
call you another time and say I need
your help which one are you more apt to
help you want to give you money or the
one who gave you time and energy and
that this this is a good lesson for
leadership as well giving our time and
energy is often more powerful than
simply just throwing money at someone
let's say there's one person who started
their own little business a little
consultancy right got my shingle out I'm
a consultant right and everywhere they
go they keep telling you that they're
better than everyone else
uh they keep telling you they're smarter
than everyone else they keep telling you
that you know the big the problem with
the big companies is is they don't have
the flexibility I'm it it actually gets
the point of being annoying to the point
that we don't want to actually work with
them because we don't believe them right
um
because
um now let's let's change the change the
scenario you meet that same person and
and they introduce themselves look
there's a lot of good good Consultants
out there
um some of them are a lot better than me
um but I wake up every single day to be
a better version of what I do today than
I did yesterday and I can tell you the
device I give today is even better than
it was yesterday and the advice I'm
going to give tomorrow is even better
because for me it's an education and
that's why I love working with
open-minded wonderful clients who are
partners because what we end up doing is
growing together
right now that's one person think about
how appealing that person is they've
actually told you
that you may actually get as good or
better advice somewhere else but it's
who they are and who they're being in
the disposition that they bring that
make them way more trustworthy and uh us
wanting to work with them
um and it's the same for big companies
it's got nothing to do with the size of
the company which is it's called
humility and honesty I remember young in
my career I experienced this myself when
I when I went off and hung my shingle
out and I was a little I had a little
marketing company a little marketing
consultancy I remember going into
meetings and the client would say we
want you to do all of this for us and
I'd say I'm really good at that pretty
good at that okay at that really bad at
that I highly recommend you hire
somebody else to do that and I'm happily
partner with them for them to do that
and the clients wanted to work with me
more
not even though I just told them I can't
do that only because I was the only one
who was honest everybody else they talk
to big or small told them that they were
great at everything which is just not
true nobody's great at everything and uh
and so it's amazing when you take the
risk to be honest it pays dividends in
the trust that you build what I think is
really interesting is think of a date
like uh uh like a job interview right
um and think of a job interview like a
date right so
um if you went on a on a first date with
someone and they sat down they said you
know
um
I'm extremely rich
um I've made lots of money I do lots of
cool things I've met a lot of famous
people
um I go on TV all the time which is good
because I'm really good looking uh yeah
yeah would you want to go on a second
date with them right not very appealing
it's also not very appealing when we sit
down for a job interview and just tell
people how great we are and all the
things that we've done it's the same
kind of thing now imagine if you knew
you or why and you're making a
conversation with someone uh and they
say so you know where are you from what
you know tell me a little bit about you
and you say you know
I love what I do I love my life I love
my job you can say I I wake up every day
to inspire people to do the things that
Inspire them and for me the challenge is
finding all the different ways that I
could do it
um and I've been really really grateful
for the path that it's taken me and I've
I've made some money and I've got to go
on TV which is fun because I'm really
good looking and you can see how all the
same jokes and all the same things now
have a context and that's what why it
does it provides context it also helps
you connect with somebody that when
somebody's telling you about themselves
and you ask some questions and you get
to know them a little bit and you
realize that maybe their values are
completely different than yours so y
gives you Clarity and confidence in who
you are and what you need around you but
it also helps you present yourself in a
way that's way more authentic now
there's a there's a there's a rub to the
why that I don't talk about that often
um uh because you really have to get
good at giving your why before you can
deal with this but the the difficult
part about knowing your why is the thing
that you give to the world the value you
give and offer refer to other people is
also the thing you need the most so it's
one so one of the ways to to to to
um understand the people in our lives
partners and Mates is can they actually
give us the thing that we give to other
people you have to be clear and open
about what you stand for and just like
when you hire somebody
you want to make sure that when you hire
them that they share your values that
they believe in your vision you know
they don't just think it's corny you
know or marketing but rather that they
they buy into it and sometimes we'll
make mistakes and sometimes people will
come and they fall in love with it after
the fact but we it's you know we try on
balance to bring people that we believe
will get along with the people who work
here because of our values and our and
our cause and so too is it with with
with suppliers
um I think that um uh or or clients it's
the same thing which is we stand for
what we stand for and our goal is to
attract people who believe what we
believe the the more vocal we are about
what we believe those people literally
will come to us or turn down a
competitor who may even be cheaper
because they would rather do business
with us and so it's okay to do business
with a supplier that doesn't believe
what we believe but we have to go in
with eyes open knowing full well that
this is just a transaction you offer a
decent product you give me a decent
price this is not going to be a lifelong
relationship this is a transactional
relationship
and when it's done I'm just going to
hold you to very different standards
right because when it's transactional
we're a little less patient when things
go wrong
um
and sometimes we kid ourselves you just
can't do that too often it's like if
you're living a healthy lifestyle you
can have chocolate cake just not too
often
um so yeah I think the more vocal you
are the more you attract and then you
have to make decisions like you're
hiring people because they're going to
become a member of your family as well
this is the difference between the
short-term finite minded and the
long-term infinite minded the finite
minded is it the cheapest today is it
the best relationship today and pay no
attention to the secondary or tertiary
effects and definitely pay no attention
to what will happen in five years
whereas that long-term minded
infinite-minded uh player
um looks at some it's it's looks at
something and and looks at someone and
says well you know you're not the
cheapest but I think we're going to get
along just fine and over the course of
time the quality of work will far away
what have you paid a friend of mine
who's a consultant loves to joke about
her clients that they never have the
time or money to do it right the first
time but they always have the time and
money to do it again
and I think when you're infinite minded
you consider those factors from the from
the beginning if I ask you do you need
to change and you said to me no I'd be
worried you know like you think you
figured everything out like emotionally
professionally all your relationships
everything's golden oh okay how's that
working out for you you know I think the
answer is always yes which is to view
ourselves or our organizations as Works
in progress you know that is an infinite
mindset infinite mindset is
fundamentally constant Improvement so
you know there's big change there's
little change there's tweaks there's
dramatic change sometimes it's reacting
to changing cultures uh changes in
culture politics technology you know
sometimes the change is our own
sometimes we have to react to it but I
think the honest answer is yes we have
to change there's always opportunity to
improve something
so there's this notion in businesses
that people fear change which is just
fundamentally not true people fear
Sudden Change you know
um but incremental change is not
threatening people feel fear change that
threatens them right and very often the
way we change manage uh is we do lots of
PowerPoint presentations about what's
coming and don't worry and we have all
these things and we we treat it very
rationally and what we're ignoring is
the emotional response now there are
some people who who love change
um it's a it's an infinite minded thing
to embrace uncertainty to see
opportunity in surprise for some people
especially people who have been who have
gotten good at doing something for 10
years 20 years
um that all of a sudden you say you're
gonna change it they fear again there's
that emotional word they fear that
um they won't know how to or it will set
them back and so no number of rational
assurances will help them get over that
at some point we have to just let them
go through the process we Bandy these
words around a little too quickly these
days they all kind of mean the same
thing you know authenticity and tension
you know purpose flow all these things
you know of course it matters what is
the what is the birth of this motivation
is it for PR is it is it to hire
Millennials because that's what they
want so we'll give it to them you know
uh uh is it is it because the street
demands it or is it is it because it's
something I fundamentally believe in I'm
I'm very for with the round table
announced the statement's a bit pablum
but you know reads like a you know the
generic values that put on the wall of a
generic company
um uh I would have liked to have seen
them the people who they attribute the
work to in the press release to folks
like Kip Tyndall from Container Store or
Jim Senegal from Costco who've been
leading this way for decades and have
been outspoken about the way business
has been done and been criticized for it
for decades like they're better
Messengers for it because they're deeply
they have that deep intention they
fundamentally believe business should be
done this way and the true infinite
minded player
wants to build a business not just to
Build a Better Business for themselves
it's they want to build a business
because they want to build business
better so they don't just come up with
an idea and then hoard it they come up
with idea and share it because it's good
for the game it's about perpetuating the
game so if the intention is to see All
Ships rise then then I'm very open to
what these these companies are saying if
the intention is to see our ship rise I
become a little cynical be the leader
you wish you had become a student of
leadership study it read about it watch
things about it practice it every day
you know like be a parent you know like
join the movement means I'm going to
take care of my team sometimes I'm in a
leader leadership position and sometimes
I'm not and it doesn't matter I'm going
to practice leadership if I'm a
salesperson you know I'm if I'm if I
work at the if I work at uh the check
Encounter of an airline I'm going to
take care of the people I work with I'm
going to take care of the customers as
if as if they're my family you know like
practice leadership learn about it study
it because I do these things because I
recognize I'm just a piece of a a puzzle
you know it's one of the reasons I
wanted to come talk to you on camera
it's because you know when we do a
jigsaw puzzle the first thing you do is
lean the picture the the Box against the
wall and then you start putting the
pieces together to build that picture my
job in this movement I'm the guy who
points at the box right I'm the one
who's pointing at the picture pointing
at the picture maybe pointing out a
couple of the pieces and where they go
but I need
lots of people to join me we need lots
of people to join us who say I have a
piece of the puzzle I'm willing to lead
this way I'm willing to abandon Milton
Friedman ideals and and do something
bigger something more follow that you
know live with an infinite mindset lead
with infinite mindset
um and put their piece down and say how
can I help build that Vision we we need
the Army and so how people can engage in
the movement is actually practicing all
the stuff more than anything else that's
what we need the best leaders are
actually the best followers in what ways
what do you mean
um the best leaders never think that
they're the final that the buck stops
with them they always believe that
they're in service to something bigger
than themselves and even if that leader
uh the person in leadership position
gets to the tippy top of whatever
organization they still feel that
they're subordinate to something even
bigger right so uh uh the Pope
this still thinks that he's in service
to something bigger than than him right
a CEO of a Visionary organization
feels that they are still beholden to
and in and following a vision bigger
than them so the best leader is actually
the best follower is even if they're at
the highest levels of the organization
they're still in service right it may
not be to a person but to a cause
whatever it is there's still some sort
of something that they're beholden to
and they're devoted to and they're in
service to
um so so followership is a thing
um and
um
not to belabor the Marine point but uh
you know Marines when they evaluate
their leaders they're looking good for
good leadership and good followership so
for example there when you go through
OCS officer candidates uh School
selection
um uh
when somebody's a for a task you know
chosen to be the leader of that group
for that task the the Marines are
watching the others as well so they're
looking to see that everybody's
contributing ideas and they're looking
to see that that leader takes in those
ideas but is decisive and and they're
looking to see that the the members of
the group if their idea isn't picked
they still give their all
to see that that the leader's idea is
successful and if it fails give it their
all to pick up the pieces and and see
what they can do as opposed to going I
told you right should have gone my way
right right I was right or sabotaging
because their idea didn't get picked so
they go all in so so good followership
is is as important as good leadership
that that we we respect that that
um when a decision is made we will we
will give our Blood Sweat and Tears to
see that the decision our leaders have
made will be successful and if it fails
we will help pick up the pieces because
that's the deal
will one thing make them work together
um uh I shared incentives is also a part
of thing usually all we do is give
individual incentives which means we're
only incentivizing Behavior to work
individually
um uh and by the way incentives don't
always have to be Financial it can be
just recognition and reward you know
catch people doing things right so when
you see people helping each other and
sharing call it out publicly you know
compliment publicly criticized privately
in front of the rest of the team
um give people promotions when there's a
behavior that you want to promote like
like teaming
um but also ask people to solve problems
together and and thank them together and
if one person comes to you and complains
I'm doing all the work you say well why
don't you find out what maybe they're
struggling maybe they're like we have to
push push back
um uh and also I think the most
important thing is leading by example
um asking for help I mean when the
leader acts like they know everything
and they have all the answers then all
it's doing is telling everybody else you
better know everything and have all the
answers because that's how you're going
to get ahead here and so I think one of
the most difficult things for anybody in
a leadership position to get comfortable
with is is saying I don't know or I need
help or can somebody help me or can you
do this with me
um I love working I love teaming with
folks on on my team it doesn't matter
what the rank structure is bring in
someone Junior let's work together
um even if all they're doing is poking
holes you know do you think this is good
no I think it can be better okay let me
try again
um so I think I think demonstrating the
behavior that we want is a big part of
it
depending on the size of the
organization obviously
um
it's very common that other team members
will go to the leader and say we don't
want to work with that person I mean
that that's usually a big highlight you
know
um that's frequent
um uh you can tell in meetings very
often if somebody is domineering but I'm
also a great fan of peer reviews quite
frankly
um uh the the Army Rangers dealt with
this they called them Spotlight Rangers
when when candidates were going through
Ranger school they had to in the past
they had this issue where these very
talented Ranger candidates and the T and
the instructors loved them so they
looked like they were great candidates
the problem is as soon as the spotlight
was turned off
they were horrible people so leadership
didn't know
and so they implemented peer reviews so
now you have to be good at your job your
instructor has to like you and your
colleagues have to like you you're
you're you're and so
um and by like I mean respect and you're
you know you you're seen as a team
player and help each other out so um if
all you're doing is reviewing annually
someone's performance
that's insufficient there needs to be
regular feedback mechanisms
um and there needs to be an open open
dialogue and peer review 360 review
where you all come into a room and you
get to give each other feedback in real
time
um but yeah it's probably because there
aren't enough metrics what is your
advice for somebody that's in a company
that they they don't have an infinite
minded culture don't don't be there no
don't try and influence that which you
cannot influence don't control that
which you cannot control you know an
infinite mindset means
that is something I can do but I can
influence and take care of the people to
the left of me and to the right of me I
can take care of the people who work for
me I can even take care of the person I
work for sometimes we have a toxic boss
not because they're bad but because we
don't understand the pressure they're
under sometimes to Simply exhibit
empathy to our boss you know hey boss
you were really harsh on us today
everything all right what's going on I'm
worried about you you know I'm here like
we can we can succeed together I'm we're
here to help you you know if we're no
matter where we are inside an
organization leadership is not about
rank or authority leadership is taking
responsibility for the people around us
and so any anybody on any team at any
rank at any level can be a leader
the first choice is that we have to want
to be a dear friend of mine Lieutenant
General George Flynn from the Marine
Corps said that the first Criterion to
being leaders you have to want to be one
so any of us can volunteer to be a
leader
um and that's what you do you commit
yourself to seeing that the people with
whom we work on a daily basis love
coming to work they feel that someone's
got their back they feel supported they
feel that they have top cover they feel
someone cares about them as a human
being listens to them knows their story
allows them to be themselves we can be
that leader and what you start to see is
those teams becomes really high
performing those teams become super
tight and you start to hear rumors
across the company because everybody
wants into that team because apparently
it's a great team to work with to work
on
um and before you know one of those
people goes and moves to another team
and they take everything that they learn
because leadership is learned and they
do it for another team and if we take
that infinite mindset
and eventually the tail will Wag the Dog
and it doesn't matter if it's this CEO
or another CEO because we will Outlast
whoever's in charge right now and that's
the goal we're doing this for the good
of the organization we're doing this for
the good of the Cause right and the tail
can whack the dog
so leadership and Authority are not the
same thing
title affords you Authority affords you
rank right
um but that doesn't make you a leader I
know many people who sit at high levels
of organizations who are not leaders
um we do is they tell us because they
have authority over us
but we don't trust them and wouldn't
follow them anywhere
um and we I know many people at low
levels of organizations that have no
formal rank no formal Authority but
they've made the choice to look after
the person to the left of them and and
take care of the person to the right of
them uh and we would trust them and
follow them anywhere
um and so rank affords you the
opportunity to lead at scale
it affords you with the opportunity to
take care of more people Implement
systems and and incentive structures and
all the rest of it reward behaviors to
to to to to you can influence culture
with rank but that doesn't make you a
leader and you still have to study the
the the the the tenets of leadership and
and and when they align it's magical you
know when you have Rank and you and
you've been studying leadership then you
can then you can actually affect the
culture in a in a more robust way and
and one of the primary responsibilities
of any leader is to make more leaders
and and you can do that at scale if you
have authority leadership is not about
being in charge it's about taking care
of those in our charge and the Very
responsibility of a leader is not to
drive performance leaders are not
responsible for the results leaders are
responsible for the people who are
responsible for the results and the
problem is is we don't teach people how
to lead right when you're very very
Junior we give people tons of training
how to do their jobs some people get
Advanced degrees how to do their jobs so
that they'll be good at them and if
you're really good at your job will
promote you and eventually you get
promoted to a position where you're now
responsible for the people who do the
job you used to do and we don't teach
you how to do that so how can we expect
people to be good at their jobs if we
don't train them how to do it like would
you go see a doctor that didn't go to
medical school no so why would we work
for a leader who has no training in
being a leader
that's why we get managers that why
that's why we get micromanagers that's
why we get toxicity it's not because
they're bad people it's because they
don't know what they're doing and
they're making it up as they go along
and those lucky times that we get to
work for a great leader well they were
lucky that they probably had a great
leader before them or they learned it
somewhere else or maybe they had a
terrible leader and they committed to do
the total opposite of everything the
point is they learned it well we have to
teach leadership so that leaders can
create environments in which all of us
can work to our natural best that
produces trusting teams the power
belongs to the people this is a this is
just an anthropological truth sure you
know the power always belongs to the
people which is why dictators bus in
crowds to to give the appearance that
they're popular or they actually have
fake elections to give the appearance
that they have a mandate
dictators do that right if if the if the
people didn't have the power dictators
wouldn't need rallies and they wouldn't
need elections right right
dictators fear the people
right
because people have the power in any in
any population in any organization and
what keeps dictators and bad leaders
authorities in power is by keeping the
people divided because if you can create
mistrust amongst neighbors
um
then the people can never come together
and never depose the leader and so if
you look at any dictatorship that ever
existed there are systems look at East
Germany during the Cold War you know we
didn't know who was telling on us so
everybody kept to themselves and nobody
trusted anybody neighbors didn't trust
neighbors and that allows authoritarian
organizations to to do as they please
the people which when people come
together you know it's it's not it's not
it's not Congress that just woke up one
day and decided the Civil Rights Act
that's a pretty good idea it was
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people marching you know in in peaceful
protest
[Music]
um that put unbelievable pressure
on a on a on a system to change and
anything that's ever happened in the
world where there's been revolutional
Revolution happen this way yeah people
always have the power and this is very
true in the business as well the people
have the power and so if we have mass
layoffs on an annualized basis and you
create internal competition what you're
doing is you're pitting people against
people especially if you create a system
where we're only incentivized based on
individual performance so in a sales
organization for example if my income
literally depends on how many sales I
get and you're gonna I'm Gonna Keep
stuff away why would I help you yeah
right keep the people divided you keep
the system that we've got but as soon as
the people come together
good things happen we are the sum total
of how we were raised and the
experiences we had we when we were kids
good or bad and what I find remarkable
when I've done these and I've asked
people tell me a specific early happy
childhood memory and sometimes somebody
will stare at me and very uncomfortably
say I did not have a happy childhood I
don't have any happy memories
and I'll say well tell me a sad one then
and uh and so here here's one of the
actual things that somebody told me
um they had a very a very abusive father
and one of the things they remember is
uh her and her brother her baby brother
hiding from their father when he went on
a on a rampage and she remembers holding
her brother and covering him up while
they hid in the closet and she tells
this traumatic difficult sad story
and it occurred to me while I was
listening to the story I said you told
me about how you made specific attempt
to cover your brother to protect your
brother that's positive in other words
what you'll find is even in difficulty
you will find these these these
strengths that come out and that's who
this person was this person at her core
was a protector that she would stand in
the way of those uh uh who who who might
be harmed in other words it was very
very positive
I'm a great believer in the world of
balance that there's a cost for
everything that is good that happens to
us or everything we gain comes at a cost
but everything bad also offers some
silver lining there's always a positive
and something bad that happens as well
so the the one of the dirty secrets
about finding your whys you actually
don't have to have happy childhood
memories you just have to have childhood
memories
um and there are still patterns in there
that reveal who you actually are and so
some of those coping mechanisms
um though in their specific form I would
venture to say that there's still some
things that came out of that that helped
make you who you are that offer you
Great Value how do you create the
environment where people are going to
thrive and create those results that
you're talking about what does it you're
asking me the question
um uh what does it mean to be healthy
you're asking me the question what does
it mean to be a great parent like I
don't have five things to be a great
parent right it's a lifestyle and it's
comes number one with the commitment
that I'm responsible for the life of
another human being the growth of
another human being the closest thing to
leadership is parenting you have to be
an infinite student of parenting you
know you want to be a parent you ask
your friends you ask your own parents
you join groups you read magazines you
watch talks whatever it is you're
constantly consuming how to deal with
this constantly changing challenge of
being a parent and it's ups and downs
and successes and failures you know and
that's what it is leadership is the same
leaders great leaders are students of
leadership no matter how achieved they
may be
they're still learning
um and it's a lifestyle it's the
lifestyle of what I need to do to look
after people which includes things like
listening
uh learning how to give and receive
feedback
um learning how to have effective
confrontations how to discipline when
necessary in a way that's constructive
um
roam the Halls get to know people
learning what it means to to ask
somebody questions how do you ask
questions
you know like some people are naturally
good at being curious about other human
beings and some people are uncomfortable
because they're introverts or whatever
socially awkward but we can learn you
know how do you learn to remember
people's names well I'm bad at names no
you've just decided you're bad at names
we can learn to be good at names so that
when we walk down the hall and say hey
Tom
oh my God he remembers my name it's a
nice feeling it's a lifestyle it's a
lifestyle there are many many things we
have to do and constantly work on to be
a great leader to create that
environment those of us who believe that
there's a better way to build a
corporate environment those of us who
believe that we're that it is that that
that being able to say I love my job as
a right it's a it's not a privilege it's
not for a lucky few who get to go home
at the end of the day it's like I love
my job right it's not some some Lottery
that you win you know you know you go to
a dinner party and you ask them to do
like your job and they go I love my job
and we go oh you're so lucky they didn't
win anything right
it's not luck right we are entitled it
is our it is our god-given right to love
going to work why is that
because I think human beings are tribal
animals and all of us want to feel
inspired we all want to feel like we're
a part of something bigger than
ourselves we all want to have some sort
of physical and psychological safety
whether it's at home or work you know we
we fear War We Fear crime and we we want
to feel psychologically safe at home we
want safety and at the end of the day
every human being on the planet
once the feeling that I can provide for
myself and my family there's nobility in
work you know
um
handouts
don't work and they and they destroy the
human ego you know there's nobility in
being able to to do a hard day's worth
of work and and collect a paycheck and
when I do really well somebody says good
job here's a little extra for you
because you're a valuable member of the
tribe and we want to make sure that
we're incentivizing the behavior that
you're doing and the behavior you're
doing is you're taking care of something
bigger than yourself so I am
uncomfortable with this concept of
work-life balance
um because balance is achieved with two
opposing forces and why should work in
life be an opposition right and uh I I
don't think there's if you don't have
work-life balance if you're struggling
to find work-life balance no amount of
yoga will fix that right
um taking off an extra week of vacation
and by the way vacation means you're not
working on the beach that's just
telecommuting from a beach
um
um but I believe in in uh that the that
you're able to build a life where work
and
personal life become uh
not only you say interchangeable but
smooth
and what I mean by that is they're not
necessarily confined by hours in a day
but rather where I choose to give effort
so for example if it's four o'clock in
the afternoon technically part of the
work day and you're hankering for a run
because it's a day like this
you can go for a run like that's you
know and one of the things one of the
mistakes that I've made was treating
things that are important to my mind my
body my spirit as stuff something that
I'm supposed only supposed to do off
hours or on weekends
but just like I can't decide when I have
an idea sometimes it's on Saturday and
sometimes it's in the evening I also
can't decide when I need a break
sometimes it's something I feel that's
something I plan for and so
we've gotten really good it's imperfect
you know sometimes responsibility takes
precedence but we have gotten really
good in our little company that if
somebody wants to take
an afternoon to be with their kids they
put in their calendar with my kids a
long time ago I used to have when I when
I had um a different form of business
before all of this stuff we used to have
things called duvet days which I I get I
can't remember we had like five duvet
days a year or something and a duvet day
was you wake up in the morning
you just don't want to come to work
you're totally healthy
or it's a beautiful day and I just would
rather go to the beach
so you'd call up and leave a message at
eight o'clock in the morning or seven
o'clock in the movie like hey I'm taking
a duvet day I'll see you tomorrow
and no one would bother you right and
people like that's amazing that you do
that Simon like people are doing that
anyway it's called
hey I think I have a 24-hour bug I'm not
going to be at work today and they go to
the beach
so just call it out
um you know schedule
time at the gym in the middle of the day
if that's when you like working out and
I just found the the more seamless that
we can make work in life
um the more we start to enjoy both more
because they're not they're not opposing
first of all I don't like the term
failure I like the term falling I think
you need we fail fast well
the problem with the word fail is it's
like the word cancer right if you have
stage for a lung cancer or stage for
liver cancer and you have a mild
melanoma
with a 99.99 chance of you'll be fine
both of those things are called cancer
and the problem is they're not the same
thing and failure is the same is the
same which is failure could be
absolutely catastrophic or it could be a
minor hiccup but the problem is we call
it failure so I think we need to use
different terms right failure I believe
is something we want to avoid but
Falling is something that happens
naturally and we want to fall and get
get up more often that's what I think is
full full Fast and get yourself back up
as opposed to lying on the ground and
complaining right so I I want to embrace
falling because that's that's taking
risks that's trying you only fall when
you push the boundaries right
the the the language matters because it
changes our mindset especially because
it's too broad a definition for failure
so one of the ways we Embrace falling is
by when somebody does fall we don't say
what have you done we go okay try again
as Leaders right
um
or
um how can I help you fix it and we just
a little more relaxed about it and and
we don't swoop in and do it for them
right but rather we go so in other words
we're encouraging risk-taking we're
encouraging people to try recognizing
that they won't lose their jobs that
that especially if you're more Junior
you really couldn't do anything that
brings down the firm anyway and we have
to give people the opportunity to fall
and let them either learn to fix their
own problems or guide them so that so
that they can every single one of us has
screwed up a bazillion times the only
reason we are where we are today is
because somebody said all right all
right you're an idiot but try again you
know like that's where I know who did it
for me Peter and tomagio my old boss
years and years and years ago go the guy
would never answer any of my questions
Peter what should I do what do you think
we should do I'm like oh
if I knew I wouldn't be asking well what
do you think I think we should do this
then do that
what are you gonna do
you know but I never felt fear that I
would get fired ever
I never felt afraid that my job was on
the line when I screwed up
we have to do that for people
existential flexibility is the
willingness to make profound strategic
shifts in order to advance your cause
180 degrees right this is not the daily
flexibility that you need in business a
leader or even us as individuals
may never have to perform an existential
Flex
um and at most you might ever have to do
it in an entire career once or never
but the responsibility of the of any
leader is to prepare their organizations
for an existential Flex should it need
to happen so what is an existential Flex
um so the best case is really uh Steve
Jobs
um and his just cause uh jobs and
Wozniak had a very clear just cause
which is to empower individuals to stand
up to Big Brother right they're
revolutionaries at heart and they saw
the personal computer as a brilliant
tool to help them advance that to
empower individuals to stand up to the
big brother and Steve Wozniak imagined a
time in which an individual could
compete in business against a
corporation thanks to a personal
computer
depression right
um Apple's already had success from the
Apple One the Apple II it's already a
big company Steve Jobs is already a
famous CEO and in December of 1979 jobs
and a bunch of his senior Executives go
and visit Xerox Park which was xerox's r
d division
and Xerox shows them
a new invention of theirs called the
graphic user interface that allows a
user to click a mouse on a desktop to
move icons and folders to use the
computer instead of having to learn an
entire computer language now jobs who
believes in empowering individuals seize
this technology and says to his team we
have to invest in this graphic user
interface thing
and the voice of reason I guess in the
team says Steve we can't
we can't do it we've already invested
millions of dollars in countless man
hours in a different strategic direction
if we suddenly change directions we're
going to blow up our own company
to which jobs actually said better we
should blow it up than someone else and
that decision led to the Macintosh the
first properly graphic user interface
computer that had in mass-market appeal
that was so profound
that the entire platform of Windows
Windows 2.0 was basically designed to
act like a Macintosh you know and the
reason we all have computers on our
desks today the reason it's a household
appliance the reason any one of us can
compete against a corporation is because
of this profound shift he was willing to
do that now I call it a capacity for
existential flexibility because it's not
shiny object syndrome which you know too
many entrepreneurs are subjected to you
know this is it this is it guys you know
flavor of the moment
um uh it's done with the very specific
reason of advancing the cause I found a
better way to advance the cause
and you have to have the just cause
otherwise how do you know what to shift
and you have to have the trusting teams
because you will put the organization
through short-term hell and that and the
numbers probably will go down in the
short term and the team has to be
willing to say we agree we understand
why you're making the shift let's do
this and it's going to suck but we're in
and they hunker down and they figure it
out if you don't have a just cause
you're literally just chasing something
and uh if you don't have the trusting
teams this happens a lot where sometimes
the leader has the just cause but the
team doesn't know it
um and if you don't have the trusting
teams then people will think you've lost
your mind and they'll start abandoning
[ __ ] or you respond to the pressures
from Wall Street or outside because the
numbers start to go down
um but but uh existential flexibility
like I said if you don't have to do it
you have to prepare the organization for
the for your success for your successor
to be able to do it which means keep the
cause alive and and maintain the the
trusting teams yeah human beings Homo
sapiens been on this planet 50 000
years-ish right and for 40 of those 50
000 years literally four-fifths of our
our time on this planet we lived in
populations that were never larger than
about 150 people
and we didn't all live on top of each
other I mean they were communities
um and the way we survived in these
dangerous times when we took care of
each other you know we contributed some
people built things some people hunted
the things some people made food some
people we took care of the kids and
their families and um and and the wealth
was distributed
um
um you know there's there's evidence
they found in anthropological digs where
the best cuts of meat which you would
think would go to all the alphas because
I'm the strongest I get to choose the
food first you know the best cuts of
meat which they can tell by the bones
are actually distributed amongst the
tribe in other words the the alphas the
leaders yes they were entitled to eat
first that's just the way we are we're
hierarchical animals you know nobody has
a problem but somebody
more senior nobody has a nobody has
visceral contempt for the idea that
somebody more senior in an organization
makes more money than me we're okay with
our outfits getting better treatment
yeah you know nobody has a problem with
celebrities you know making more money
getting getting a table in the
restaurant that we have to wait for it
right we're okay with it you know it's
one of the reasons we all try and you
know increase our our standing in in
society by doing good and you know
hopefully you do it in a good way not
just getting you know internet famous
which is getting Fame without any
contribution to society different
subject right
um but it was it was a it was
um it was shared hardships shared
sacrifice for the good of each other you
know that doesn't mean there was an ego
and selfishness of course but at the end
of the day we needed each other yeah and
then about 10 or 12 000 years ago when
we started farming we didn't need to
travel anymore we could stay put
um and we could also sustain much larger
populations
um than about 150
um because we could because we could
amass resources this also allowed for
ruling classes and intelligency and
things like that you can have an entire
group of people who didn't hunt and
didn't gather they just governed you
know
like it's a ruling class that's what it
is right or they just thought about it
philosophers yeah like you could we we
had the resources for that and we were
okay with it and it's a good thing
because look at the advancements in
modern society in the past 10 000 years
simply because we we couldn't we you
didn't have to go to oil the field you
you could actually go invent something
could innovate you could innovate right
so it's a good
you know we were not naturally made for
living in large populations
um and so the way it worked best is when
when we when we organize into smaller
groups which is why hierarchy matters
which is why leadership training matters
um so you asked about is the tough
person responsible no the top person is
responsible for taking care of the
people uh in their direct responsibility
and ensuring that they are charged with
and incentivized to take care of the
people you know with their direct
responsibility who are charged with an
incentivized to take care of the people
in their direct responsibility and the
people on the front lines are actually
doing all the work feel taken care of
and
and are happy to contribute yeah there's
a marine that I know
who's a Marine General who says the way
he can judge the quality of a lieutenant
is he listens he listens to how the the
troops talk about their Lieutenant so
when he's not around
is it the lieutenant or is it our
Lieutenant they take possession of their
leader wow right that's our Lieutenant
right versus that's it's always the
colonel it's never our kernel it's
always the colonel because there's no
relationship it's too too distant right
um so as soon as we take possession
emotional possession of our leaders
there's a there's a sign of devotion and
mutual trust but that relationship
starts with how the leader leads you
know yes we have a responsibility to
give back but we call you leader not
because you have the rank we call you
leader because you took the risk to
trust first
we you took your we took all your leader
because you took the risk to build the
relationship first you took the risk to
create the circle of Safety First you
took the risk to go head first towards
the vision first that's why we call you
leader because you undertook an element
of risk you literally lead you went
first right right nothing to do with
rank we all carry a narrative
um someone's lazy
um someone stupid
someone doesn't care someone's only in
it for themselves these are narratives
that we carry and the problem is when we
evaluate their behavior through our
narrative we it'll become it will become
self-reinforcing we will see the things
that reinforce our narrative and the
problem is then we'll treat them that
way if we've decided someone's laser
we're going to treat them as lazy so
there's a great exercise to do which is
literally take out a piece of paper and
when we're struggling with someone to
think what are the 20 other things that
could be going on in their life so yeah
number one they're lazy possible it's
absolutely possible number two they're
having trouble in their marriage uh
number three their
um things have gone wrong and they and
they don't know how to ask for help
number four they're still struggling
with the trauma of covid number five
their kids are flanking out of school
like all of a sudden we realize there's
a lot of other reasons that could
explain their behavior and we will then
treat them accordingly we will treat
them with greater empathy you know
instead of walking to someone's
classroom and saying what the hell
you're you know your performance is
still down I've had this conversation
with you before you got to get your
performance up or I don't know what's
going to happen
or you can walk into their classroom and
say your performance is down we've had
this conversation before are you okay
I'm worried about you we we they have a
problem but they aren't necessarily the
problem and even if ultimately it does
become that they're a bad fit the
culture they're still they are still not
the problem they still are just a bad
fit for the culture they have a problem
we can help them solve that problem by
going to help them relocate to a
different School District where they're
going to be so much happier we're going
to be so much happier everybody gets to
be so much happier so the other story I
was thinking of is the story of Alan
Mullally
when he took over Ford
um Ford is losing money hand over fist
in other words performance was in
Decline and when he sat down with his
most senior Executives and he asked for
a report on how their divisions were
going regular green every single one of
them delivered PowerPoints with all
green slides
and he said at the end of the meeting
how can everything be green if we're
losing billions of dollars
and they just sat there and he had
another meeting same thing all green and
he said the same thing how can
everything be green if we're losing
billions of dollars the problem was the
previous leader if you delivered a red
slide you got fired
and so there is no way that anybody was
going to tell the truth
because their job depended on it
and so one executive took the risk to
turn one slide red
and malali said thank you for the the
the the visibility that's great
transparency now how can we all help him
fix that problem he has a problem he is
not the problem all the other Executives
thought he was going to get fired turns
out he wasn't and slowly but surely
everybody including leadership could
finally get a clear and transparent view
of what was actually going on in their
organization and they worked together to
solve the problems if somebody was
struggling people said how can we help
you rather than I'm fine you're the one
that's screwing everything up so it's a
great way to think about it there's a
whole industry around I think work-life
balance yes yeah it's like there's a
massive industry that's just trying to
teach this and help people with
work-life balance yeah the problem seems
like it's failing treating well it's
treating a symptom isn't it you know
it's
you know it's like so many things in our
life so here's the bad analogy
um so we buy running sneakers and they
have really thick you know this yeah
they have really thick heels tons of
padding in the heel right but that's
because people don't know how to run
right because we land with our heel
which is bad for our joints you know
you're not supposed to have an extended
knee yeah all of it you're supposed to
be a toe planter where your knees are
always bent I mean you know all this
yeah so instead of teaching people how
to run
what we do is we just build shoes with
more padding in the heel
and treat the symptom rather than the
Cause right and uh uh I think it's it's
the same thing you know uh uh we we
treat symptoms instead of the cause
so so the work-life balance thing what
we're doing is instead of instead of
changing businesses instead of changing
the way a business operates and changing
the way in which we teach leaders to
operate with an infinite mindset so that
we more naturally have work-life balance
and let's be Crystal Clear what
work-life balance means you know doing
more yoga does not create work-life
balance right that's the that's the shoe
that's the cushion on the shoe right
yeah what what the the imbalances I feel
safe at home I don't feel safe at work
that's the imbalance and no amount of
yoga or vacation time
is gonna fix that what fixes that work
life imbalance is better quality
leadership in our businesses
and then what you'll find is the balance
but instead what we do is we have an
entire industry that's treating the
symptom that's putting that's putting
cushion on the shoe to to make us feel
kinda for an hour right that I've
achieved balance you know
but it's just for an hour and you know
we literally Market you know companies
Market themselves as helping provide you
work-life balance unless you're teaching
leaders to the people who are my bosses
then you are not helping me achieve work
like mountains you're helping me numb
the pain you have me cushion the blow we
are designed to take care of each other
as social animals it is in our biology
that we will take care of each other
this is why it feels so good when
somebody does something really nice for
us with no expectation of anything in
return we've all had the experience
where somebody does something nice and
you're like oh my God thank you and then
they put their hand out you're like oh
it kind of like ruins the whole
experience completely it ruins it but
when they just do it and they're like no
no and you're like please like no no no
it's my pleasure yeah you know not only
does our esteem for them go up but it
just it feels good likewise it feels
good when we do something for someone
else with no expectation of anything in
return when we give our time and our
energy money actually doesn't work
believe it or not like if I told you I
gave 500 to charity this morning you'd
be like okay that's great Simon but if I
told you that last weekend I gave up my
Saturday and went to Painted schools in
the inner city you'd be like nice that's
really awesome now the value of my labor
was worth a lot less than 500 and that's
the point right that's the point which
is
um we are designed to take care of each
other and there's a chemical called
oxytocin which is the chemical
responsible for our feelings of love and
friendship and Trust when you look at
somebody you adore and you go like this
that's oxytocin when somebody touches
you and says oh my God it's so good to
see you touch creates oxytocin so good
to see you yeah you know it actually
makes us feel closer to each other you
know
when oxytocin is released in our bodies
not only does it make us feel good not
only does it boost our immune systems
but the more oxytocin we have in our
bodies it actually makes us more
generous because the human body is
trying to get us to look after each
other and it gets even better than that
the person who does the act of
generosity giving of time or energy
without expectation of anything in
return they get a shot of oxytocin the
person on the receiving end gets a shot
of oxytocin
and even witnessing an act of generosity
or kindness releases oxytocin it feels
good to see somebody do something nice
and the more oxytocin we have in our
bodies as I said means we're more likely
to do something nice for somebody this
is the biology of pay it forwards it's
the human body's desperate attempt to
get us to look after each other and so
when we create environments where we
allow that to flow it does naturally it
just takes care of itself it's just
biology
um when we create environments where we
restrict that it actually does the
opposite it releases a chemical cortisol
which is the feeling of stress and
anxiety cortisol actually inhibits
oxytocin which means if we work in a
poorly LED organization not only do we
have high stress but we actually it
actually inhibits empathy and in other
words I'm less likely to even want to
care about somebody because of the poor
leadership and the poor environment
that's been provided for me to work in
right and the more cortisol we have in
our bodies stress goes up anxiety goes
up it affects our immune systems happy
people live longer happy people have
lower rates of cancer diabetes and heart
disease which means when you're in a
position of leadership you're actually
medically responsible for the lives of
these people get the environment right
they will live longer they will suffer
lower cases of disease and they will
probably have happier families because
of it whereas if you're a bad leader
over the course of time you're actually
killing the people working with you our
jobs are actually killing us I recognize
that business is an infinite game and
almost all of the leadership in business
today is finite minded and so there's
literally you can't show up to a game of
basketball ready to play football like
it's not going to go well we overuse
Sports analogies in business
but Sports has beginning middle and end
there actually is a Finish Line right we
overuse the analogies they're incorrect
analogies you know running a business is
the same as as getting healthy it's a
lifestyle leadership is a lifestyle an
infinite mindset is a lifestyle right so
for example you can't get healthy by
going to the gym for nine hours it
doesn't work right
um but if you go every single day for 20
minutes
you'll absolutely get into shape 100 but
I don't know when and it's different
times for different people right and
leading is the same thing you can
absolutely have fitness goals you can
absolutely have finite goals within the
infinite context of being healthy but
there's a practice that you have to do
you have to get enough sleep you have to
go to the gym you have to eat well you
have to protect your relationships you
know because healthy relationships
really matter to our health and you have
to do all those things vigilantly and if
you miss your health goal it's okay you
keep working at it and you know you will
hit it business is the same who says
that you have to meet this goal on this
arbitrary date now it helps to drive and
it's good to have incentives and we
we're very goal-oriented species that's
fine but if we miss the thing it's fine
we just keep working towards it like
their guidance they're not absolutes
because they're arbitrary dates and
arbitrary numbers and even if you do hit
your Fitness goal you don't get to stop
working out
you have to keep going for the rest of
your life right and this is what leading
with an infinite mindset means here's an
example this is a normal scenario in
business right we will give a team
um a target a goal to hit by a certain
time frame usually a year
um because that's usually when we pay
taxes right
that's the only reason things are done
in years right if we pay taxes every 18
months all the goals would be 18 months
right
so we usually give people a financial
Target and there's two teams one that is
driven solely by hitting that goal
because all they care about is getting
their bonus at the end of that goal
morale is up and down if they happen to
have a good month morale is up if they
have a bad month morale is down
retention is terrible they can't hold on
to employees nobody really trusts each
other the boss is toxic and right before
the end of the financial year they have
some mad push where they're dropping
prices all over the place and they're
managed to drive revenues and hit the
goal right the problem is we bonus that
team we bonus that leader because of
what uh because of the goal they hit
right and basically what we're doing is
spreading a message to the rest of the
company saying we don't care how you get
there we don't care if you step on your
people we don't care if you act
unethically if you hit your number
you're going to do very well in this
company versus another team that's doing
extremely well it's good steady slow
growth like really really On Target you
know not the highs and lows the Peaks
and valleys morale is super high
retention is amazing it's a model team
they trust each other they share
information and they miss their goal on
the agreed upon date right at the end of
the year they're just shy of it but
clearly you can see see from the trend
data they're going to hit it at 13 or 14
months the problem is we don't give that
person anything we don't give that team
anything
right and this is part of the problem
when you have an infinite mindset
absolutely have the goals but the trend
matters more how you get there matters
as much if not more and we pay attention
to that so even if I hit my fitness goal
I'm eating better I'm sleeping better my
relationships are great I'm going to the
gym yes I miss my goal but I know if I
just keep going I'll hit it I'm getting
healthier and healthier right I just got
the timing wrong and this is what we
need to build into business that
infinite mindset yes have the goals yes
have the Ambitions yes have the annual
targets if we miss them as long as we're
doing the right things we have the right
lifestyle to take us there that's a much
healthier way to live a life and a much
healthier way to build an organization
heck man I've disagreed with my own
ideas you know I've been pig-headed and
dogmatic about this is the way we gotta
go and everybody is wonderful and and
like falls apart they're just like okay
yeah I kind of screwed the pooch on that
one yeah but I take accountability yeah
you know or we find in the middle
somebody goes hey if we do this we can
probably be more successful and we pivot
there's there has to be at the
decision-making ranks there has to be a
humility that the ideas don't always
have to come from me right Bob Gaylor
the fifth chief Master Sergeant of the
Air Force is the best definition of
humility I've ever heard he said don't
confuse humility with meekness
humility is being open to the ideas of
others so you know it's not about like
oh shucks that's not humility you know
you and I know some remarkable leaders
people of great power and authority and
they have huge egos yes you know they
know they're good and they don't mind
talking about how good they are but when
somebody says hey I got an idea they
lean in like they're little kids they go
let's hear it you know I'm looking at
some of the photographs on your wall and
some of the folks that I know here they
have an insatiable curiosity for ideas
and even though they're unbelievably
accomplished if you have something to
share with them they want to talk about
it they want they want to hear about it
that's humiliating to me you know so
it's not this you know it's not me it's
you know
self-confidence is a good thing thinking
you're better than everyone else that's
unhealthy oh that's good yeah you know
thinking you're good is healthy thinking
you're better than others is unhealthy
what are your thoughts around courage
how do people get the courage to to play
the long game to not the long game it's
the infinite game because a long game
could be five years right true yeah this
is forever
uh how do people build that everything
that we're talking about in the infinite
game is really really really really hard
it is so much easier to build a company
based on short-term Ambitions than it is
an infinite cause it just is right it's
also fun right until it's not
um less inspiring but sometimes
sometimes fun right hitting a goal feels
good right
um it's much easier to just hire and
fire people frequently higher fast Fire
fast as to hiring slowly and and firing
slowly because we we try and take care
of our people as best we can it's just
it's hard to build teams all of that
stuff we talked about leadership like
what am I supposed to do to build a
trusting team well I wish I could give
you a list of five things it's really
really hard to be a parent
it's much easier to be an uncle or an
aunt or not have kids right it's hard
right so why do it you know it's fun and
and exciting to be to try and beat our
competitors you know but to to have to
face our own weaknesses every day oh
that's exhausting you know existential
flexibility I'd rather not I just would
rather not
you know so so the reason this takes
courage to completely change our mindset
a about the game that we're actually
players in
um and how we want to approach these
things and do we want to shift our
mindset and our organizations to prepare
for the infinite game to be organized
for the infinite game it takes courage
because we're going to be swimming
Upstream in a world that is very finite
driven you know the pressures on us are
overwhelming from Wall Street or our own
egos or from internal incentive
structures or our bosses whatever it is
the pressures are overwhelming for us to
play the finite game
and so how do you stand up to massive
external pressure courage
and courage is something that comes from
relationships
you know it's external a a world famous
trapeze artist would never attempt a
brand new death-defying act for the
first time without a net they would
never do it so why do we think that we
could do something difficult without
external support too
um I've had the opportunity to meet real
heroes people who've risked their lives
to save the lives of others with the
belief that they were going to die
and they didn't and when I asked why did
you do it they all say something similar
which is they would have done it for me
it's external and so we have to have we
have to take the time to Foster and take
care of people around us to nurture our
relationships because when we're going
to be doing something difficult when
we're going to be swimming Upstream when
we're going to be innovating and and and
and doing something different there are
days we're going to doubt ourselves
there are days we're going to get
knocked on our ass there are days that
storms are going to rise and we have to
have people who say I got you back
you need to do this we need you the
world needs this keep going I believe in
you you know
um
and so courage courage comes from from
not only our willingness to do that for
others but then their willingness to do
it for us and we commit ourselves to a
just cause and we're willing to to do
those things then
you know the great thing is we take a
lot of people with us and change the
world for the better and isn't that sort
of the point of an infinite life to
leave this world in better shape than we
found it to leave the companies that we
work for in better shape than when we
started to leave our families stronger
and better capable than than what they
can do without us you know isn't isn't
that what it means to live an infinite
life that we can literally live on
beyond our own lives
we take accountability away from people
and we don't even realize it yeah so
we're actually destroying people's
confidence or ability to make decisions
because we keep answering their
questions or making decisions for them I
had a boss many years ago uh one of the
best leaders I ever had Peter and
DiMaggio and
um he wouldn't answer a single question
I asked it drove me absolutely nuts hey
Peter you know what should I do well
what do you think we should do well I
I'm I think we should do this he goes
well you should give that a try then you
know or he would just ask me questions
he goes well have you considered this I
went no he goes well maybe think about
that you know but he would never tell me
the answer he'd always tell me the
parameters
um what he told me was self-reliance it
was the most valuable lesson I probably
ever ever learned
um very often you know somebody will
come and say you know should we go with
blue or green
I'll go with green well we just answered
the question once I go with the one you
think we should go with
what should we do here make the decision
you think is the right decision to make
you know and then let them make the
decision and when we give people
accountability the amazing thing is they
rise to it yeah but we keep taking the
accountability because we keep answering
all the questions so there's a very easy
lesson for everyone here is
um stop replying to all the emails that
you're getting while you're away
right like I know what happens you know
in every break or
right now uh you know there's an email
that says you know should we go with
this one or that one and you're replying
and in every break you're going to reply
to all your emails and tell people your
opinion of what you think they should do
versus saying I'm going away for a few
days for this conference so I can learn
to be a better leader
um hold down the fort while I'm away
if there's an emergency figure it out
you know
um or only call me if you absolutely do
not know the answer
um and stop replying to all the emails
and they now have to work you're giving
away uh responsibility one of the
reasons they don't take responsibilities
because they don't give it to them how
do you develop self-confidence we're
kind of going off here now but I'm this
is a topic I'm really passionate about
right now I believe uh self-doubt is one
of the biggest Killers to anyone's
Dreams yeah so how does someone develop
self-confidence and sustain it with the
ever going changes and stresses and
uncertainties that always come up once
you reach a certain level there's a new
uncertainty no
so I think it's ironic that we call it
self-confidence
because I don't for one think it comes
from the inside
I think our self-confidence comes from
the outside
right I mean that's the wrong way of
going about it or you think that's where
it comes from in general
that we are being misdirected by the
name when we say build your
self-confidence that's the instruction
is saying go inside
look inside oneself but I think that's I
think that's I think that's a false
Direction children aren't born
self-confident
their confidence is built from their
parents and their friends and their
teachers
where they're rewarded when they do well
and they're pushed when they fail
when they can do better simply you know
we know this that simply telling kids
that they're great all the time actually
doesn't build self-confidence actually
does the total opposite right right
um and I for one I can tell you my in my
own experience my own self-confidence
um uh a hundred percent comes from the
relationships that I have
um it's not some deep internal fortitude
you know a world famous trapeze artist
is not gonna try a brand new
death-defying act for the first time
without a net
so it's the people in my life
um it's it's when when I do doubt myself
that somebody says you got this
when somebody says
I believe in you when somebody says no
matter what happens whether it succeeds
or fails I'm going to be by your side
that's when I have the confidence to do
difficult things wow right I don't have
some natural battery that I that that
just
right you know that that to me is
bravado yeah I don't know about
self-confidence you know you know
being a huge risk taker
is not an indication of self-confidence
to me you know
jumping out of a plane and jumping out
of a plane with a parachute are two
different things right right
um
um to me self-confidence is measured and
there should be a degree of of of doubt
um but but I I think true
self-confidence belief in oneself and
belief in one's cause you know I could
not do the things that I'm doing and I
would not have the strength
um to have made the sacrifices that I've
made or continue to wake up on a daily
basis to drive to spread this message
um if I were alone and so when we talk
about building one self-confidence I
think the mistake that we make is that
we look inside I think the reality is
we're trying to build our
self-confidence we should be looking to
our friends we should be nursing our
relationships when I'm looking to build
my self-confidence the question is who
around me do I need to take care of you
know the way we bid our self-confidence
is by helping somebody else build theirs
right it's an act of we will build our
confidence with an act of service we're
social animals our happiness our joy our
success everything is dependent on our
relationships
um and we respond to the environments
we're in you can take a good person and
put them about it in a bad environment
and they're capable of doing bad things
likewise you can take a person that the
group or even Society has given up on
and you put them in a good environment
and they're capable of turning their
lives around and really making something
remarkable out of themselves
we are social animals and we respond to
the environments we're in and leaders
are responsible for building that
environment and if you create an
environment in which people feel safe
amongst their own
we will naturally the natural human
response to those conditions is trust
and cooperation
remember trust and cooperation are
feelings they're not instructions
there's no PowerPoint or pitch that you
can give it upon the end that someone
will trust you you can't tell somebody
trust me it doesn't work that way their
feelings
um likewise if you create an environment
where we actually fear each other fear
the people with whom we work the natural
human reaction to that that environment
is paranoia cynicism mistrust and
self-interest that's what happens
there's enough danger outside the
organization there's enough stuff going
on outside that we should have to fear
the people we work with or fear our own
leaders
and most leaders don't get this most
leaders think leadership is about being
in charge no it's not it's about taking
care of those in your charge most
leaders think everybody works for them
nope you work for the people in your
organization it is your responsibility
to take care of them make them feel safe
and they will naturally want to
cooperate and work hard and give you
their blood and sweat and tears to
advance your vision all they ask is you
take care of them make them feel valued
and valuable and the rest takes care of
itself it's like a parent it's like a
coach teach them train them give them
the opportunity to fall and try again
um and and if they fear the leader then
they're gonna take steps to protect
themselves from the leader it's
pervasive in our world today if you work
in an organization where we're at
standard practice for employees to feel
the need to send a cya email after every
single decision they make that is a sign
that they are taking time and energy out
of their day away from doing their job
in order to protect themselves from
their own leaders that's what that is
you know anybody who keeps a file of all
the good things they've done in their
career just in case they need it yeah
that is people taking time and energy
away from doing their jobs in order to
protect themselves from their own
organization
so you can't ask those people to give
you the best of their thinking and be
more productive if you've created an
environment where they're forced to
protect themselves from you you know
and this is what I learned and so it's
all about this environment the circle of
safety we come to work feeling
uncomfortable that some of the decisions
that are being made
don't benefit the good of the employee
that it really benefits this this
artificial constituency that we call the
shareholder which is really just a bunch
a bunch of institutional investors
there's this shareholder myth because
there's been a steady decline of the
middle class being involved in the stock
market for years and the whole point of
the stock market was that we all get to
share in the wealth that we helped build
because it's on the back of Average Joe
employees that produce the great wealth
in the nation and the whole point of the
stock market The Genius of the modern
day Corporation The Genius of the public
company was that we all get to share in
the wealth that we're helping produce
unfortunately over the course of the 80s
and 90s we've seen systems produced
where we're seeing the general
population the middle class actually be
less included in in that success and the
reason I wrote the infinite game was
because I myself got tired of being told
by people in positions of Authority or
people of extreme wealth that I was
naive that I don't understand how
business business works and for many
years I believed them I thought maybe I
am the dumb one right we all kind of
feel that because they have the power
they have the authority they have the
money they know more than we do
but we still go to work and feel
uncomfortable and it turns out that that
discomfort that gut feeling that says
that there's something wrong here turns
out that the majority actually knows
something
and to me this is a World is Flat moment
that that the the the the people who've
learned to game the system that this
discomfort that we feel we're we
actually are right like they actually
don't understand the game they're in
business is an infinite game and when
you play with a finite mindset lots of
people suffer including the companies
that they themselves are trying to build
that's the great irony the great irony
is the way you build great companies is
with an infinite mindset the way you
build great companies is by prioritizing
people before profit the way you build
great companies is will before resources
um both both things important but there
has to be this General leaning where we
can feel when we come to work and feel
like we're part of something bigger than
ourselves where we feel that our work
and our effort is worth more than simply
the money we make what I'm saying is
that the business needs to operate in a
way in which in which uh uh they care
about their people more and uh and and
then these arbitrary finite things
aren't the end-all be all right and
create an environment which we can have
stressful moments but there's not this
sustained stress with the steady every
day every day of Our Lives which we know
has contributed to increases in cancer
diabetes and heart disease I mean our
jobs are literally killing us yeah
um so I think short bursts of stress are
not the problem the life that I live is
actually I think pretty healthy yeah
it's this it's this steady drip of
cortisol when you go to a job where you
you know where we don't believe that our
bosses care about us and the company
doesn't care about us and they have
annual rounds of layoffs to balance the
books every year they don't they see me
as a number and then then the company
has the audacity to say you know
Millennials Aren't Loyal it's not what
are you kidding me it's like they've
entered into a Workforce in which
they're just treated as a disposable
commodity why should they be give you
loyalty show a little loyalty to your
people and you'll be amazed the Loyalty
they give back right so I think that's a
much unhealthier environment and that's
what I rail against there are five
practices in order to lead uh with an
infinite mindset
um you have to have a just cause
you have to have trusting teams
you have to have a worthy rival you have
to have a capacity for existential
flexibility and you have to have the
courage to lead
so just cause we have to give our people
something to advance a cause so just
that they would be willing to sacrifice
their interests in order to do so in
other words turn down a better paying
job or frequent business trips or
working late hours and though I may not
like those things I do them because it
feels worth it because I believe in what
I'm a part of here because I feel that
I'm helping Advance because there's no
achieving in the infinite game the goal
is not final achievement the goal is
advancing to progress in the infinite
game and to have that vision of an
idealized state of the world
um that
um all men are created equal right it's
an ideal that a nation is striving
towards that will never actually get
there but will die trying that's the
point and we can offer people the same
thing inside an organization in fact we
have to
um to give them something to advance now
how is this different from the why a why
comes from the past it is an origin
story every single one of us has our own
unique why it is our Birthright it comes
from the sum total of how we were raised
as kids it is objective you have one and
you have one for the rest of your life
the only one right and the rest of our
lives are about making the decisions
that help us uh keep in balance with our
why a just cause doesn't come from the
past it just causes about the future
it's about where we're going right you
can have multiple just causes you can
have one professionally you can have one
personally you can have one for your
family you can have one for your church
and we're involved in all of these
there's massive pressure put on people
especially young people too what's your
vision well we're not all Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates we're not all Visionaries we
don't have to have a vision but we do
have to find a vision that we can find
someone else's vision and we are so
compelled by it that we want to make it
our own that's what it means to go work
for a company with a Visionary leader
that we believe in that Vision so
clearly that we take their vision and we
make it our own and we will happily
contribute our work our effort in order
to advance what is now my vision right
Martin Luther King had a vision he stood
on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial and
told us his vision but his vision became
our vision so I may not have come up
with that Vision but I found it and I'd
like to devote time and energy to help
Advance it even Beyond him leadership is
a responsibility to people around us
it's not a rank
um you've heard me say this before I
know many people who sit at the highest
levels of organizations who are not
leaders right they have authority and we
do as they tell us because they have
authority over us but we would not
follow them right and I know many people
as do you who sit at lower levels of
organizations who have no formal
Authority and that they've made a choice
to look after the person to the left of
them and look after the person to the
right of them and we would trust them
and follow them anywhere in other words
leadership can come from anywhere with
an or within an organization yes we have
the right to demand to have better
leaders and better leadership in our
companies but when we don't quitting is
not the only option nor is simply
complaining but undertaking the task of
being becoming the leader we wish we had
wow you know anyone at any level can can
become a student of leadership and
anyone at any level can choose to take
to to look after this person and that
person and work tirelessly to see that
they rise they become better versions of
themselves and that they show up to work
inspired and go home feel feeling
fulfilled and feel safe when they're at
work because of us
it's akin to how do we be more authentic
you know
um and and the way so many companies
tackle that is they go and do market
research
right we go and do focus groups uh to
find out how we can differentiate
ourselves
um which I think is funny which is the
which is the same thing as asking your
friends sort of how should I talk to you
and how should I dress so that you'll
like me more
and your friends are going to look and
be like what you're like how do you want
me to talk to you and how do you want me
to dress so that you'll like me more
because I care
and your friends would be like I don't
know just be yourself
right and this is what companies do they
go get outside advice
to how to be themselves how they should
how they should present themselves to
the outside world
um the way you differentiate yourself is
you is you are yourself it sounds silly
but it's true which is you know what
your vision is and your causes you know
what you stand for you know what your
your culture is which means you know
what your values are just like a person
right and you work hard imperfectly
because like a person we're imperfect
and messy and you work hard to do things
that represent what you stand for and
operate in a way that represent your
values and what starts to happen is you
start to stand out because you're
consistent and people start to be able
to say I know what you stand for and you
start to become predictable and you're
either very attractive to some people
who believe what you believe or you
people don't like you because they don't
believe what you believe both of those
things are good and then there's always
people in the middle who just want to do
business with you because the
transaction is good and the the you know
the price happens to be right the
product happens to meet a certain spec
certain specs I'll do business with you
but it's it's the ones who believe what
you believe it's the loyal ones that
make a car that make a company stand out
um and do more to spread the good word
of your organization than you could ever
do with advertising and so it the irony
is is live true to your values make
decisions consistent with what you stand
for which is seen by employees as well
as customers by the way people who
believe what you believe want to work
there and want to be loyal to the
company because working here says
something about who I am
um you know if I say I work for Apple
you actually know something about me
even though you know nothing about me
just because apple is good and by the
way there's no difference between a
customer and an employee it's just a
behavioral difference either work for
you or or I buy from you but ultimately
I believe what you believe the behavior
may be different
um so I think that the best thing a
company can do to stand out is is to is
to stand for something and live by its
own value because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want the eight steps to
end laziness and procrastination check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there what we do is we kind
of check out because it feels
overwhelming or we check out because
we're afraid or we check out because we
start listening to self-doubt and then
we make these teeny tiny decisions